Thank you, Senator Arlen Specter. Just a great guy. Why are we all here? To support Senator John McCain and Governor Palin. Hello, Pennsylvania.
谢谢你，阿伦·斯佩克特参议员。真是个了不起的人。我们为什么聚在这里？为了支持约翰·麦凯恩参议员和佩林州长。你好，宾夕法尼亚州。
John McCain spends a lot of time in Pennsylvania these days. Last week, he hit Pittsburgh, Harrisburg, Moon Township, and Bensalem. The week before, he was in Montgomery County, Downingtown and Chester, and Governor Palin was in Lancaster and Scranton. Not many states get this kind of attention. Pennsylvania is the one blue state, the one state that went for John Kerry in 2004, that John McCain is vigorously campaigning in.
约翰·麦凯恩最近在宾夕法尼亚州花了很多时间。上周，他去了匹兹堡、哈里斯堡、月亮镇和本萨勒姆。前一周，他在蒙哥马利县、唐宁敦和切斯特，而佩林州长去了兰开斯特和斯克兰顿。没有多少州能得到这种关注。宾夕法尼亚州是唯一的蓝州，也是2004年支持约翰·克里、而约翰·麦凯恩正在大力竞选的唯一一个州。
In the last few weeks, a lot of people have been asking, why? Barack Obama has held double-digit leads over McCain in nearly every poll in the state. He's heavily outspending McCain on TV ads here, as he is everywhere. He has a bigger field operation in Pennsylvania than McCain's, more offices, more people, and they've been in place for months longer. And finally, thanks to voter registration drives, there are now 1.2 million more registered Democrats in the state than Republicans. That's twice as many as in 2004. And remember, the Democratic presidential ticket won the state in 2004, just as it won in 2000, and 1996, and 1992.
在过去的几周里，很多人都在问，为什么？在宾夕法尼亚州几乎所有的民意调查中，巴拉克·奥巴马对麦凯恩都保持着两位数的领先优势。他在这里的电视广告投入远超麦凯恩，就像他在其他地方一样。他在宾夕法尼亚州的竞选团队规模比麦凯恩大，办公室更多，人员更多，而且他们早几个月就已到位。最后，多亏了选民登记活动，该州登记在册的民主党人比共和党人多出120万。这是2004年的两倍。请记住，民主党总统竞选团队在2004年赢得了该州，就像他们在2000年、1996年和1992年赢得胜利一样。
So why is John McCain fighting so hard for this state? Well, part of it is pure electoral college math. He needs Pennsylvania. He needs it badly, because winning Pennsylvania is the only way he'll be able to make up for red states that might go to Obama, states like Colorado or New Mexico. And apparently, McCain sees an opportunity in Pennsylvania. This is the state where Hillary Clinton trounced Barack Obama by nine points. And so, there are tons of working class Democrats who McCain sees as persuadable.
那么，为什么约翰·麦凯恩要如此努力地争夺这个州呢？嗯，部分原因是纯粹的选举人团数学。他需要宾夕法尼亚州。他非常需要，因为赢得宾夕法尼亚州是他弥补那些可能倒向奥巴马的红州（如科罗拉多州或新墨西哥州）的唯一途径。显然，麦凯恩在宾夕法尼亚州看到了机会。这是希拉里·克林顿以9个百分点大胜巴拉克·奥巴马的州。因此，有大量的蓝领民主党人，麦凯恩认为他们是可以被说服的。
McCain campaign officials have told The New York Times and others that their internal polls show that Obama is just seven or eight points ahead, which seems less daunting when you realize that five or six percent of the voters are still undecided and up for grabs. And in this last week, most of the polls, even the ones you read in the paper, show McCain gaining on Obama in Pennsylvania. And closing that gap is what these rallies are all about.
麦凯恩的竞选官员告诉《纽约时报》和其他媒体，他们的内部民调显示奥巴马仅领先七八个百分点，当你意识到仍有百分之五或六的选民尚未决定且可以争取时，这似乎就没那么令人望而生畏了。而在最后这一周，大多数民调，即使是你从报纸上读到的那些，也显示麦凯恩在宾夕法尼亚州正在追赶奥巴马。而这些集会的目的就是为了缩小这一差距。
So at this time, it is my great pleasure and high honor to introduce to you the next president and vice president of the United States, John McCain and Sarah Palin.
因此，此时此刻，我非常荣幸地向大家介绍下一任美国总统和副总统，约翰·麦凯恩和萨拉·佩林。
[CHEERING AND  APPLAUSE]
[欢呼和掌声]
After this rousing introduction by Congressman Charlie Dent, everybody leaps to their feet, the houselights go black, spotlights swoop and circle, and then nothing, absolutely nothing, no McCain, no Palin. After six minutes on our feet, some people start to sit down. A couple minutes later, "Eye of the Tiger" comes on the PA and everybody jumps to their feet again, but nope, false alarm, no candidates still.
在查理·登特众议员发表了激昂的介绍词后，每个人都跳了起来，室内灯光变暗，聚光灯扫来扫去，然后什么都没有，绝对什么都没有，没有麦凯恩，也没有佩林。站了六分钟后，有些人开始坐下。几分钟后，《虎之眼》在广播里响起，每个人又跳了起来，但不，虚惊一场，候选人还没到。
Finally, 43 minutes later, the Straight Talk Express bus pulls right on to the floor of the arena. Governor Palin and Senator McCain take the stage.
终于，43分钟后，“直话直说”号巴士直接开到了竞技场内。佩林州长和麦凯恩参议员登上了舞台。
And it's got to happen right here in the state of Pennsylvania, my friends. I'd like to give you a little straight talk. Pennsylvania will have a great role in determining the next president of the United States and vice president of the United States. I need your vote. We need to carry Pennsylvania. We need you.
朋友们，这一切必须就在宾夕法尼亚州发生。我想给你们一点“直话”。宾夕法尼亚州将在决定下一任美国总统和副总统方面发挥重要作用。我需要你们的选票。我们需要拿下宾夕法尼亚州。我们需要你们。
[CHEERS AND APPLAUSE]
[欢呼和掌声]
For the last month, our radio staff has been in Pennsylvania to try to understand what is happening on the ground in this election. We chose Pennsylvania because it's one of the true battlegrounds this year. We chose Pennsylvania because it's a microcosm of the country, with a couple big cities and sprawling rural areas and small towns and suburbs.
过去一个月，我们的广播团队一直在宾夕法尼亚州，试图了解这次选举在当地的情况。我们选择宾夕法尼亚州是因为它是今年真正的战场之一。我们选择宾夕法尼亚州是因为它是国家的一个缩影，有几个大城市，广袤的农村地区，小城镇和郊区。
We wanted to see firsthand what arguments were affecting undecided voters, and making decided voters change their minds. And all this hour we will be deep inside the field operations in both camps, McCain's and Obama's.
我们想亲眼看看哪些论点影响了未决选民，并促使已决选民改变主意。在这一个小时里，我们将深入了解麦凯恩和奥巴马两个阵营的现场运作情况。
And so, as we head into this last week before Election Day, we bring you the ground war in this crucial swing state. We're going to be hopping around the state throughout this hour. And so, before we start, a quick Pennsylvania electoral primer.
所以，在选举日前最后一周，我们为大家带来这个关键摇摆州的地面战。在这一个小时里，我们将会在全州各处奔波。在开始之前，先来一个快速的宾夕法尼亚州选举入门指南。
It's pretty simple really. There are two big cities, Philadelphia and Pittsburgh, one is on the right side of the map of Pennsylvania, the other's on the left side of the map. Those are the Democratic strongholds. The reliable Republican territory is the vast area between those cities, which is farmland and small towns.
其实很简单。有两个大城市，费城和匹兹堡，一个在宾夕法尼亚州地图的右侧，另一个在左侧。那是民主党的据点。可靠的共和党领地是这两个城市之间广大的区域，那里是农田和小城镇。
James Carville once famously described the state as Philly and Pittsburgh with Alabama in between. So, what's up for grabs? Well, a lot maybe.
詹姆斯·卡维尔曾用一句名言形容该州：费城和匹兹堡，中间夹着阿拉巴马。那么，有什么可以争取的呢？嗯，也许很多。
Incoming call. Incoming call.
呼入电话。呼入电话。
Democrats for McCain, can I help you?
“支持麦凯恩的民主党人”，我能帮到你吗？
Now, officially, this is a citizen's for McCain office, in Scranton, Pennsylvania, in the northeast part of the state. But the office is run by Democrats, and the name that they have given on the phone speaks for itself. Democrats are the key to McCain's strategy in Pennsylvania, his campaign told us. This is the Hillary vote, which, as I said, was huge in this state.
正式来说，这是一个位于宾夕法尼亚州斯克兰顿的“公民支持麦凯恩”办公室，该州东北部。但办公室由民主党人运作，他们在电话里自称的名字说明了一切。麦凯恩竞选团队告诉我们，民主党人是麦凯恩在宾夕法尼亚州战略的关键。这就是希拉里的选票，正如我所说，在这个州规模巨大。
And McCain's campaign is unabashed about the pursuit of it, both in Pennsylvania and nationwide. Check out this ad.
麦凯恩的竞选团队毫不掩饰对这部分选票的追求，无论是在宾夕法尼亚州还是全国范围内。看看这则广告。
I'm a proud Hillary Clinton Democrat. She had the experience and judgment to be president. Now, in a first for me, I'm supporting a Republican, John McCain. I respect his maverick and independent streak, and now he's the one with the experience and judgment. A lot of democrats will vote McCain. It's OK, really.
我是希拉里·克林顿的骄傲支持者。她有担任总统的经验和判断力。现在，作为我的第一次，我支持一位共和党人，约翰·麦凯恩。我尊重他那特立独行和独立的性格，现在他才是那个拥有经验和判断力的人。很多民主党人会投票给麦凯恩。真的，没关系。
I'm John McCain and I approve this message.
我是约翰·麦凯恩，我批准这条信息。
One of the producers of our show, Nancy Updike, spent some time in Scranton at the Democrats for McCain office.
我们节目的制片人之一南希·厄普代克在斯克兰顿的“支持麦凯恩的民主党人”办公室待了一段时间。
When I told an Obama supporter that I was doing a story about Democrats for John McCain and that I was on my way to interview one of them, she said, oh, so you're going to interview an ass [BLEEP]. Other names she could have used, according to the McCain Democrats I talked to, based on their previous experiences: whack job; dumb, racist KKK bitch; and a word I can't say on the radio that begins with the letter "C."
当我告诉一位奥巴马支持者我正在做一个关于“支持麦凯恩的民主党人”的故事，并且正要去采访他们中的一员时，她说，哦，那你就是要去采访一个混蛋[哔]。根据我采访过的麦凯恩民主党人的说法，基于他们之前的经历，她本可以使用其他词：疯子；愚蠢、种族主义的3K党婊子；以及一个我在广播里不能说的以“C”开头的词。
Country first.
国家第一。
[CHEERS AND APPLAUSE]
[欢呼和掌声]
Country first. Country first.
国家第一。国家第一。
These are former Hillary Clinton supporters, about 40 of them, who've ridden two-plus hours in cars and a bus from New York on a Saturday to canvass in Scranton for John McCain. They overwhelm the tiny Democrats for McCain office, and fill it up with the squeals of long-lost friends reunited, and the enthusiasm that comes from working very hard for something you believe in with all your heart, for no money.
这些是希拉里·克林顿的前支持者，大约40人，周六从纽约坐了两个多小时的车和巴士来到斯克兰顿为约翰·麦凯恩拉票。他们挤满了小小的“支持麦凯恩的民主党人”办公室，到处都是失散多年的朋友重逢的尖叫声，以及为你全心全意相信但却没有报酬的事业努力工作所带来的热情。
This type of commitment is not to be trifled with. After a long, tough primary, the people in this room are tenacious, experienced, organized, and very, very mad. They're also impossible to dismiss as racist KKK bitches. A lot of them are not white, including the two I ended up following as they were canvassing.
这种承诺是不容小觑的。在经历了漫长而艰难的初选后，房间里的人们坚韧、经验丰富、组织严密，而且非常、非常愤怒。他们也不可能被简单地斥为种族主义的3K党婊子。他们中有很多人不是白人，包括我最终跟随拉票的那两位。
[KNOCKING ON DOOR]
[敲门声]
It's so they can hear. Hey, you know what, they will answer the door that way.
这样他们能听见。嘿，你知道吗，他们会那样应门。
The one giving the good, long knock is Chris, a tall, courtly, 28-year-old African American policy analyst with a graduate degree in economics. The shorter one next to him, giving Chris a look like, why are you knocking so much, is his friend Jessie, a 35-year-old African American software tester who's taking a week off from work to campaign for John McCain. They met on the Hillary campaign trail.
那个用力敲门的是克里斯，一位身材高大、彬彬有礼的28岁非裔美国政策分析师，拥有经济学硕士学位。旁边那个身材较矮、看着克里斯心想“你为什么敲这么多下”的朋友是杰西，一位35岁的非裔美国软件测试员，他请了一周假来为约翰·麦凯恩竞选。他们是在希拉里的竞选路上认识的。
It's always this kind of a sense of like, oh, I'm the black man lurking and knocking on people's doors, will they call the police? And there always this kind of thing, like on somebody's face that's kind of like--
总有一种感觉，哦，我是个潜伏在别人门外敲门的黑人，他们会报警吗？总有一种感觉，就像出现在某人脸上，有点像——
I'm lighter--
我比较浅——
Who is--
谁是——
--and smaller
——而且更小
--this person at our door, especially once it starts getting dark in the winter when we're doing the primaries.
——这是我们门口的人，特别是在冬天我们做初选时天开始黑的时候。
Hi, how are you?
嗨，你好吗？
We are volunteers for Democrats for John McCain. I'm here wondering if John McCain can count on your support this November.
我们是“支持约翰·麦凯恩的民主党人”的志愿者。我来这是想问问约翰·麦凯恩能否在今年十一月获得您的支持？
No, unfortunately you can't.
不，很遗憾，你不能。
No?
不？
OK, no. I'm having a difficult time trying to vote for anybody, but it won't be him.
好吧，没有。我很难决定投票给谁，但不会是他。
Why not, if I may ask?
请问为什么不呢？
He just reminds too much of Bush.
他太像布什了。
Really?
真的吗？
Yeah, he even sounds like him.
是的，他听起来甚至都像他。
You know, I'll tell you--
你知道，我要告诉你——
I'm trying to be real with you.
我试着跟你说实话。
No, I hear you. No, I appreciate that.
不，我听到了。不，我很感激这一点。
Scranton is overwhelmingly Democratic, and Chris and Jessie have been given a list of registered Democrats and Independents, so it wasn't surprising that they were encountering some McCain resistance. What was surprising was how ripe for conversion most of the supposed Obama supporters were. Take this guy, Paul [? Volpe ?]. It took Chris and Jessie about one minute to start wearing him down, and the more they talked about McCain, the more skeptical of Obama he seemed.
斯克兰顿绝大多数是民主党人，克里斯和杰西得到了一份登记在册的民主党人和独立选民名单，所以他们遇到一些对麦凯恩的抵制并不奇怪。令人惊讶的是，大多数所谓的奥巴马支持者是多么容易被转化。以保罗·沃尔佩为例。克里斯和杰西花了一分钟就开始动摇他，他们谈论麦凯恩越多，他就对奥巴马越怀疑。
I tell you that his record of bipartisanship is that he is more likely to vote with Democrats than he is to vote with Republicans. 55% of his legislation was passed with Democrats.
我告诉你，他的两党合作记录表明他比共和党人更有可能投票给民主党人。他55%的立法是与民主党人共同通过的。
Really?
真的吗？
Yeah. He opposed Bush on how he managed the war. He opposed him on his tax cuts.
是的。他在战争管理方式上反对布什。他在减税问题上也反对他。
Our thing is we're Democrats, and, you know--
我们的情况是，我们是民主党人，你知道——
From New York.
来自纽约。
Yeah, from New York, and we have a lot of kind of Democratic core beliefs. But I feel more comfortable knowing that John McCain, who's had years of service to this country, will be the commander in chief. And if you look back over John McCain's career, I mean, he's not afraid to get in there and be the bad guy if it means getting problems solved for people.
是的，来自纽约，我们有很多民主党的核心信仰。但我感到更舒服的是，约翰·麦凯恩，这位多年来为这个国家服务的人，将成为总司令。如果你回顾约翰·麦凯恩的职业生涯，我的意思是，他不怕进入其中并成为坏人，只要这意味着能为人们解决问题。
I  just wanted something different. That's why I was going for the other guy. You know what I mean? I just want something--
我只是想要一些不同的东西。这就是我支持另一个人的原因。你明白吗？我只是想要一些——
To change right?
改变，对吧？
Yeah.
是的。
Well, you know, John McCain is--
好吧，你知道，约翰·麦凯恩是——
From I just wanted something different, [? Volpe ?] went on to say about Obama:
从“我只是想要一些不同的东西”，沃尔佩继续说奥巴马：
Yeah, I mean, he's a real good talker, but--
是的，我的意思是，他是个很会说话的人，但是——
Been a lot of talk. A lot of talk.
说得很多。说了太多。
I don't know what kind of a doer he is.
我不知道他是个什么样的实干家。
And from that, he went to this.
从那以后，他变成了这样。
And I really don't know where Obama even came from either. You know, he popped out of-- I've never heard of him before this.
而且我真的不知道奥巴马是从哪冒出来的。你知道，他突然出现——在此之前我从没听说过他。
Who is this guy? That's what I'm always saying. I'll stop.
这是谁啊？我总是这么说。我不说了。
He's just the only one that's impressing me on TV. And you know what, you're right. It's not really a reason to vote for him.
他只是电视上唯一让我印象深刻的人。你知道吗，你是对的。这不是投票给他的真正理由。
Can't give the guy the keys to your country because he looks great on TV, you know? Because then you give, you know--
不能因为一个人在电视上看起来不错就把国家的钥匙交给他，你知道吗？因为那样你会给，你知道——
When we left, [? Volpe ?] was still uncommitted and leaning toward Obama. But if I was a pollster, I wouldn't put him in the Obama column. He'd been a Hillary supporter just like Chris and Jessie, and for him, Obama seemed like an uncomfortable bench he'd only sat down on out of exhaustion. That's what made Chris and Jessie so persuasive. They'd left the bench, and they seemed to be thriving.
当我们离开时，沃尔佩仍未表态，但倾向于奥巴马。但如果我是民调员，我不会把他归入奥巴马的阵营。他曾是希拉里的支持者，就像克里斯和杰西一样，对他来说，奥巴马似乎是他因疲惫而坐上的不舒服的长凳。这就是让克里斯和杰西如此有说服力的原因。他们离开了长凳，而且看起来过得很好。
Canvassing is usually a big time investment for a small return. In studies, canvassers had to talk to an average of 14 people to get one extra vote. But Chris and Jessie seemed to be doing a lot better than that. I watched them make inroads with one wavering Democrat after another. A whole family sitting on their porch:
拉票通常是低回报的高时间投入。研究显示，拉票员平均需要交谈14个人才能获得一张额外选票。但克里斯和杰西的表现似乎要好得多。我看着他们一个接一个地赢得了动摇的民主党人的好感。一整个家庭坐在他们的门廊上：
Can we ask if you're supporting John McCain for president this year?
请问你们今年支持约翰·麦凯恩担任总统吗？
Actually, still undecided.
实际上，还没有决定。
Oh, really?
哦，真的吗？
Yeah.
是的。
Well, hi.
嗯，你好。
[LAUGHTER]
[笑声]
A young woman voting in her first presidential election, a woman with three sons who's worried about the economy and the Iraq War and Sarah Palin. Everyone was charmed and, frankly, mesmerized by Chris and Jessie. And finally, the woman with three sons said to Chris straight out:
一位第一次参加总统选举的年轻女性，一位有三个儿子的女性，担心经济、伊拉克战争和萨拉·佩林。每个人都被克里斯和杰西迷住了，坦率地说，被他们吸引了。最后，那个有三个儿子的女性直接对克里斯说：
I'm a little surprised. I'm surprised that you're backing McCain and Palin. You wouldn't want to see Barack Obama be the first--
我有点惊讶。我很惊讶你们竟然支持麦凯恩和佩林。你们难道不想看到巴拉克·奥巴马成为第一个——
African American--
非裔美国人——
--African American president.
——非裔美国人总统。
Well, I would love to see an African American president in the White House in my lifetime. I really do. But more important than my personal desire to see an African American president is my love for this country. So I think, what does this country need most, for me to get to see an African American president in my lifetime or for somebody who has experience? Barack Obama says a lot, but what has he done? If you look at his record, you can't really--
好吧，我当然希望在我有生之年看到一位非裔美国总统入主白宫。真的。但比我个人想看到非裔美国总统的愿望更重要的是我对这个国家的爱。所以我认为，这个国家最需要什么，是我在有生之年能看到一位非裔美国总统，还是需要一个有经验的人？巴拉克·奥巴马说了很多，但他做了什么？如果你看他的记录，你真的不能——
Chris and Jessie went to 16 houses in this neighborhood in Democratic Scranton, PA, and only one was a definite Obama vote. Four were firm McCain supporters, and this was without hearing Chris and Jessie's spiel. And of the four undecided houses, Chris and Jessie flipped one to McCain and made serious headway with the other three.
克里斯和杰西在民主党重镇宾夕法尼亚州斯克兰顿的这个街区拜访了16户人家，只有一个是明确的奥巴马支持者。四个是坚定的麦凯恩支持者，而且这还没听克里斯和杰西的游说。在四个未决的家庭中，克里斯和杰西成功说服了一家转投麦凯恩，并与其他三家取得了重大进展。
For these undecided Democrats, it was like they were wearing handcuffs, and Chris and Jessie were walking around with the keys, unlocking them. Suddenly, former Hillary Clinton supporters could consider voting for a Republican and against a black man and not feel racist, or dumb, or crazy.
对于这些犹豫不决的民主党人来说，他们就像戴着手铐，而克里斯和杰西拿着钥匙走来走去，为他们解锁。突然间，希拉里·克林顿的前支持者们可以考虑投票给一位共和党人，投票反对一个黑人，而不会感到种族主义、愚蠢或疯狂。
At the end of that day, I thought, John McCain really could win Pennsylvania. For anyone wondering why he's still pouring money into the state, this is it. Ambivalent Democrats live all over Pennsylvania, and with their votes, he could do it.
那天结束时，我想，约翰·麦凯恩真的可能赢得宾夕法尼亚州。对于那些想知道为什么他还在这个州投入资金的人来说，这就是原因。纠结的民主党人遍布宾夕法尼亚州各地，有了他们的选票，他或许能做到。
Were you surprised at how open people who said, yeah, I'm a lifelong Democrat, how open they were to the idea of voting for John McCain, and even getting very interested in the idea of voting for John McCain, from what I saw?
当你看到那些说“是的，我是终身民主党人”的人，对投票给约翰·麦凯恩的想法如此开放，甚至对投票给约翰·麦凯恩的想法非常感兴趣，你感到惊讶吗？
I'm not surprised. I mean, I think that what you were seeing are a lot of people who didn't feel a strong connection to believing that Barack Obama saw them, not just looked at them, but got it, saw them.
我不惊讶。我的意思是，我认为你看到的是很多人并没有感觉到与巴拉克·奥巴马有强烈的联系，不相信他“看见”了他们，不仅仅是看，而是理解，看见了他们。
The bottom line for Chris is this, he thinks Obama is little more than a marketing campaign, not a man of demonstrated principal or grit. And compared to all that, so what that he's a Democrat?
对于克里斯来说，底线是这样的：他认为奥巴马只不过是一场营销运动，而不是一个有原则或坚韧的人。相比之下，他是民主党人又怎样呢？
Nancy Updike. We'll return to her in Scranton later in the program. Now, while the McCain campaign is hoping to pick up votes in territory that is normally strongly Democratic, the Obama campaign is fighting to pick up extra votes in that vast territory in the center of Pennsylvania that has always been strongly Republican.
南希·厄普代克。稍后我们会在节目中回到斯克兰顿。现在，尽管麦凯恩竞选团队希望在通常是坚定的民主党领地争取选票，但奥巴马竞选团队正在努力争取在宾夕法尼亚州中部那些一直坚定支持共和党的广大地区获得额外选票。
You've probably heard about the massive voter registration drives that Obama has run around the country. In Pennsylvania, a big part of that push was for young voters on college campuses, especially right in the heart of red Pennsylvania, a town called State College, smack dab in the middle of the state, where one of the biggest schools in the country is, Penn State, with 44,000 students.
你可能听说过奥巴马在全国开展的大规模选民登记活动。在宾夕法尼亚州，这项工作的一大部分是针对大学校园里的年轻选民，特别是在红色宾夕法尼亚州的心脏地带，一个叫做州学院的小镇，位于该州的中部，那里有全国最大的学校之一，宾夕法尼亚州立大学，拥有44000名学生。
The John Kerry campaign had only one paid staffer in State College back in 2004, and they lost this county. Obama has seven paid staff and tons of volunteers trying to register and get out the student vote. One of our producers, Sarah Koenig, went to see how they were doing.
2004年，约翰·克里的竞选团队在州学院只有一个带薪工作人员，他们输掉了这个县。奥巴马有七名带薪工作人员和大量的志愿者试图登记并动员学生投票。我们的制片人之一，萨拉·科尼格，去看看他们做得如何。
It's September 24, 13 more days until the October 6 deadline to register voters in Pennsylvania. The registration goal for campus is to sign up roughly half the student body, 21,000 students. It's a number the campaign wouldn't allow anyone to discuss with me on the record, but it's also a number that every single person involved with voter registration on campus was talking about.
9月24日，距离10月6日在宾夕法尼亚州登记选民的截止日期还有13天。校园的登记目标是招募大约一半的学生，21000名学生。竞选团队不允许任何人向我正式谈论这个数字，但这也是每个参与校园选民登记的人都在讨论的数字。
On the wall of the Obama office in downtown State College, there's a drawing of a giant thermometer climbing to the ceiling, with the number 21,000 at the very top. Every day, they fill in their new registrations in red marker. As of this day, they're at about 12,000, a little more than halfway there with less than two weeks to go.
在位于州学院市中心的奥巴马办公室墙上，画着一个通向天花板的巨大温度计，最上面写着21000。每天，他们用红记号笔填补新的登记人数。到今天为止，他们已经达到了12000人，距离截止日期不到两周，进度刚过一半。
Besides the Obama campaign, there are a bunch of other groups trying to register voters, all with their own goals.
除了奥巴马的竞选团队，还有许多其他团体试图登记选民，每个人都有自己的目标。
Hey, you guys want to hear a really cool rhyme? All you have to do is register to vote.
嘿，你们想听一个很酷的押韵吗？你们只需要登记投票。
Hi, sir, are you registered to vote?
嗨，先生，您登记投票了吗？
Uh-huh.
嗯哼。
Have a good day. Don't forget to vote.
祝你有美好的一天。别忘了投票。
It's less than three weeks, the deadline, and then we won't be fine. We're running out of time.
不到三周就是截止日期了，如果我们不做好，我们就完了。我们的时间快用完了。
Everybody registered to vote? You registered to vote?
大家都登记投票了吗？你登记投票了吗？
Yes.
是的。
Awesome. Thank you.
太棒了。谢谢。
Every single one of you are registered to vote at your current Penn State address? I don't believe you.
你们每个人都用现在的宾夕法尼亚州立大学地址登记投票了吗？我不相信你们。
They began in the summer. And when classes first started in late August, there was a rash of registrations, but it's slowed since then. And now, people are starting to get a little antsy and sick.
他们夏天就开始了。当八月下旬课程刚开始时，曾出现过一阵登记热潮，但那之后就减慢了。现在，人们开始有点焦虑和生病了。
[GIRL COUGHING]
[女孩咳嗽声]
A girl collecting registrations for MoveOn is looking miserable with a cold. The guy running a student group called PSUvote is cranky from a stomach bug. I meet Jonathan [? Burkhart ?] at a diner, a place he goes about once a week for breakfast. This is one luxury during campaigns. Jonathan was sent here by the Service Employees International Union, SEIU, with the singular task of registering 2,500 people by himself. He's getting sick, too.
一个为MoveOn收集登记表格的女孩得了感冒，看起来很痛苦。那个运作一个叫PSUvote学生团体的家伙因为肠胃病而脾气暴躁。我在一家餐馆遇到了乔纳森·伯克哈特，他大约每周去那里吃一次早餐。这是竞选期间的奢侈享受。乔纳森是被服务雇员国际工会（SEIU）派到这里的，唯一的任务是独自登记2500人。他也病了。
When I get really tired my eyes start to puff up, and I have like a tear duct, a minor tear duct infection.
当我真的很累的时候，我的眼睛开始浮肿，而且我有泪管，轻微的泪管感染。
By the time the registration deadline came, that minor infection turned into a major infection, the worst eye infection, in fact, that I or Jonathan's doctor had ever seen. He ended up needing surgery. But right now, taking a break is out of the question. He's still less than halfway to his goal. He's got what you might call the Schindler's List syndrome.
等到登记截止日期到来时，那个轻微的感染演变成了严重的感染，实际上是我或乔纳森的医生见过的最严重的眼部感染。他最终需要手术。但现在，休息是不可能的。他距离目标还不到一半。他得了你可能会称之为“辛德勒名单综合症”。
I mean there's an infinite amount of work that I can be doing all the time. You can never overdo it.
我的意思是，我一直都有做不完的工作。你永远无法做得太多。
Right, you could look around at all of these people and just start asking them, are you registered, are you registered, are you registered?
对，你可以环顾周围所有这些人，然后开始问他们，你登记了吗，你登记了吗，你登记了吗？
Exactly. I mean, it's sort of-- OK, so you registered half the student body, why didn't you register all the student body? You registered all the student body, why didn't you convince every single one of them to vote for your candidate? You convince every single one of them to vote for your candidate, why weren't you in other areas where you could have been convincing other people? Like, it just keeps on going.
完全正确。我的意思是，这有点——好吧，你登记了一半的学生，为什么不登记所有的学生？你登记了所有的学生，为什么不劝说他们每个人都投票给你的候选人？你劝说了他们每个人投票给你的候选人，为什么你不在其他地区劝说其他人？就像，它只是不断地继续。
Jonathan's worked in field politics for five years. He's 30, which gives him near-geezer status in the registration crowd. The guy in the Obama office who's running the 10-county region for the campaign is just 23. And mostly, other people doing registrations are in their teens or 20s. You have to be young to do this job.
乔纳森在现场政治工作了五年。他30岁，这让他在登记人群中处于接近“老头”的地位。那个在奥巴马办公室负责该竞选区域10个县的人只有23岁。而且大多数做登记的人都在十几岁或二十几岁。你必须年轻才能做这份工作。
Jonathan's the guy people come to for advice. He knows all about data analysis and attacks his goal of 2,500 as scientifically as possible. He keeps a tally of every registration he gets, sorted by day, time, sex of registrant. He notes the weather, the football games. This way, he knows, or thinks he knows, the preeminent registration times, which, so far, are 1:00 to 3:00 on Tuesdays. He's figured out that a beat-up sign gets better results than a fancy one. And he's done experiments with his pitch.
乔纳森是人们寻求建议的对象。他了解数据分析，并尽可能科学地攻击他2500人的目标。他记录了他获得的每一份登记表，按日期、时间、登记人性别进行分类。他记录了天气、橄榄球比赛情况。通过这种方式，他知道，或者认为自己知道，最主要的登记时间，到目前为止是周二的1点到3点。他发现一个破损的招牌比花哨的效果更好。他甚至用他的推销词做了实验。
The thing is, is I was doing the pitch for a few weeks, and I was switching off days that I did the pitch and then days that I didn't do the pitch. And it was unfortunate from my sort of organizer's instincts that I was getting fewer registrations on the days that I did the pitch.
问题是，我有几个星期在做推销，我交替着做推销和不做推销的日子。从我这种组织者的直觉来看，不幸的是，我在做推销的日子里获得的登记反而更少。
You've thought a lot about this.
你考虑了很多。
This is all I do.
我只做这个。
The built-in pisser of this whole endeavor is that, as each group tries frantically to reach its goal number, the pool of non-registered students is always shrinking. It's harder and harder to find someone who isn't already registered.
整个努力中最令人沮丧的地方是，当每个团体疯狂地试图达到他们的目标数字时，未登记学生的群体总是在缩小。越来越难找到一个还没登记的人。
Hey guys, how's it going? Are you all registered to vote at your current Penn State addresses?
嘿，伙计们，怎么样？你们都用现在的宾夕法尼亚州立大学地址登记投票了吗？
I'm registered to vote at home.
我在家里登记投票。
OK, let's register you here.
好吧，让我们在这儿给你登记。
Enter the master, Casey Miller. She's 22, a fifth-year, cigarette-smoking, hard-drinking senior, originally from Pittsburgh. She's in A Xi D, a sorority, and has a tattoo of a blue lion's paw on her left foot, the logo of the university's football team. On her MySpace page she lists the following interest: cars, Steelers-- the football team-- parties, late-night Cinemax, bottles of mousse, very large beer bongs.
高手凯西·米勒登场。她22岁，是个五年级学生，吸烟、豪饮，来自匹兹堡。她是A Xi D联谊会的成员，左脚上纹着一个蓝色的狮子爪，那是该大学橄榄球队的标志。在她的MySpace主页上，她列出的兴趣是：汽车、钢人队——橄榄球队——派对、深夜电影频道、慕斯发胶、超大啤酒杯。
What's your last name?
你姓什么？
Well, I was planning on sending in my--
嗯，我本来计划寄出我的——
Don't send in an absentee ballot.
别寄缺席选票。
Why not?
为什么不？
Well, I'll just get right to the bottom line. Improper completion of the absentee ballot or related material, improper delivery of the absentee ballot to the county board of elections, can result in your absentee ballot being challenged and set aside by a county board of elections or a court of law. Basically, that means it's going to get thrown out if you leave like one box unchecked or anything slightly wrong--
好吧，我直接说重点。缺席选票或相关材料填写不当、缺席选票递交给县选举委员会不当，都可能导致您的缺席选票被县选举委员会或法院质疑并搁置。基本上，这意味着如果留一个空格没勾选或者任何细微的错误，它就会被扔掉——
A situation like this, where someone says he's going to vote absentee, this is where many volunteers fail to persuade or just give up. But Casey goes on for a full 40 seconds. He's still not convinced.
像这样有人说要投缺席选票的情况，很多志愿者会放弃劝说或直接放弃。但凯西说了整整40秒。他还是不被说服。
What if the issues at home matter more to me than the issues here?
如果家里的议题对我来说比这里的重要呢？
Well, are you going to move back home after you graduate?
好吧，你毕业后会搬回家吗？
You're very forceful when it comes to registering people to vote.
你在登记选民方面非常强势。
Yes, I am.
是的，我是。
Has anybody just straight-up turned you down?
有人直接拒绝你吗？
Yes. And every time it's heartbreaking.
有。每次都令人心碎。
At this point, the full-on flirting kicks in. Casey presses Obama stickers onto the boys' chests, uses their full names with ironic formality. Steven, what's your political party? Gregory, is that a 16803 zip code?
此时，全面的调情开始了。凯西把奥巴马的贴纸贴在男孩们的胸口，讽刺性地正式称呼他们的全名。史蒂文，你的政党是什么？格雷戈里，那是16803邮政编码吗？
See, I'm going to ask you for you phone number, Keith. And I'm going to print that very clearly. So if there's anything wrong with your form, we will call you and make sure that your registration goes through and that you can vote in this election. What is you phone number, Keith?
看，基思，我要向你要你的电话号码。我会打印得非常清楚。所以如果你的表格有任何问题，我们会给你打电话，确保你的登记成功，让你能在这次选举中投票。基思，你的电话号码是多少？
Here's what you can't appreciate about Casey on the radio. She looks like a small, brunette Brigitte Bardot. Long, wavy hair swept up with a clip, thick black eyeliner painted on '60s style, huge perfect smile, knockout figure. This, in no small part, is why her registration numbers are consistently higher than anyone else's. Boys will listen to anything she has to say for however long she chooses to say it. Girls too, actually.
这是你在广播里无法体会到凯西的地方。她看起来像一个小个子的布里吉特·巴铎。长长的波浪发用发夹盘起，画着60年代风格的粗黑眼线，巨大的完美笑容，魔鬼般的身材。这在很大程度上是她的登记人数始终比其他人高的原因。只要她愿意，男孩们会听她说任何话，听多久都行。其实女孩们也一样。
But I'm just concerned that, like, I might be tempted to vote twice.
但我只是担心，像，我可能会受到诱惑投两次票。
Keith, you're just going to have to avoid temptation.
基思，你只需要抵制诱惑。
There's a good chance, statistically speaking, that Keith won't vote at all. Students have a terrible track record of actually making it to the polls once they've signed up. That's just one reason this whole registration drive is something of a gamble for the Obama campaign. Even the gurus of get out the vote campaigning, two Yale political scientists named Alan Gerber and Donald Green, can't say for sure how effective registration drives are at increasing voter turnout.
从统计学上讲，基思很有可能根本就不会去投票。学生们在登记后真正出现在投票站的记录非常糟糕。这只是整个登记活动对奥巴马竞选团队来说是一场赌博的一个原因。即使是动员投票的竞选大师，两位耶鲁政治学家艾伦·格伯和唐纳德·格林，也无法确定登记活动在增加投票率方面有多有效。
With a new voter, first you have to sign them up to vote, then you have to convince them to vote for your candidate, and then you have to make sure they get to the polls. The experts simply don't know if, dollar for dollar, it's worth all the time and money. Limited resources in any campaign.
对于一个新选民，你首先得让他们登记投票，然后说服他们投票给你的候选人，最后还得确保他们去投票站。专家们简单地不知道，就投入的每一块钱而言，这是否值得花费所有的时间和金钱。竞选中的资源是有限的。
[FOOTBALL CHEER]
[橄榄球欢呼]
We are!
我们是！
Penn State!
宾州州立！
Thank you!
谢谢！
You're welcome!
不客气！
Nine days before the deadline, there's still about 8,000 registrations to go. We're at a vast tailgate party outside Beaver Stadium before a football game. It's the largest stadium in North America. There are easily 100,000 people here, a crowd I'd characterize, overall, as drunk. Penn State is playing Illinois.
距离截止日期还有九天，还有大约8000个登记目标要完成。我们在海狸体育场外的一个大型尾门派对上，在比赛之前。这是北美最大的体育场。这里至少有100,000人，我总体上会将这个人群描述为“喝醉了”。宾州州立大学正在对阵伊利诺伊大学。
Barack Obama's from Illinois, and we're going to kill Illinois!
巴拉克·奥巴马来自伊利诺伊州，我们要干掉伊利诺伊！
Fuck Illinois.
去他妈的伊利诺伊。
We're going to kill Illinois. That's what they're screaming. Casey, though, is unphased, fearless in fact. And this is what makes Casey so valuable to the campaign. She fits in where other volunteers don't. Two nights running, she surreptitiously registered people in the women's bathroom of a nightclub. She registers people at frat houses, wanders uninvited into apartment parties.
我们要干掉伊利诺伊。这就是他们尖叫的内容。然而，凯西却毫不动摇，事实上是无所畏惧。这就是凯西对竞选团队如此有价值的原因。她在其他志愿者无法立足的地方游刃有余。连续两个晚上，她在夜店的女厕所里偷偷给人们登记。她在兄弟会宿舍登记人们，不请自入地进入公寓派对。
Just like the football games overall have been very unsuccessful for registering students. And I think it's because they stand on the corners and try to stop people, instead of approaching them at tailgates like I was just doing. And I think that that's a lot more efficient. Especially, I registered like 19 people in the line for the porta-potties at the last game. Like, do you see this line?
就像总体上足球比赛对登记学生非常不成功。我认为这是因为他们站在角落里试图拦住人，而不是像我刚才那样在尾门派对接近他们。我认为那样效率高得多。特别是我在上一场比赛的流动厕所队伍里登记了大约19个人。就像，你看到这条队了吗？
The Obama campaign has set up a tailgate here and invited former NFL players to come sign autographs and register people. Casey's job today, besides registering people herself, is to send fans to the tailgate. She goes up to a group of friends having a party under a tent and does her pitch.
奥巴马的竞选团队在这里设立了一个尾门派对，邀请前NFL球员来签名并登记人们。凯西今天的工作，除了自己登记人，就是派球迷去那个尾门派对。她走到一群在帐篷下开派对的朋友中间，开始推销。
We have Franco Harris, Kenny Jackson, Matt Rice, and Blair Thomas.
我们有弗兰科·哈里斯、肯尼·杰克逊、马特·赖斯和布莱尔·托马斯。
Are those, like--
那些是，像——
They're former Penn State players who have played for the NFL.
他们是曾为NFL效力的前宾州州立大学球员。
[UNINTELLIGIBLE]?
[听不清]?
Yeah.
是的。
One of the girls gestures at a cooler, offers an alternative.
其中一个女孩指着一个冷藏箱，提供了一个替代方案。
I have Captain Morgan. I have Carlo Rossi.
我有摩根船长朗姆酒。我有卡洛·罗西葡萄酒。
No one she tells is nearly as excited about these players as Casey is. Franco Harris is her hero. She knows all about his 1972 Hall of Fame play for the Steelers, called The Immaculate Reception. She can't wait to meet him. It's tough going here. It's really loud and a lot of people, when they're not hitting on Casey, are just obnoxious. Still, she gets some registrations.
她告诉的任何人都没像凯西那样对这些球员感到兴奋。弗兰科·哈里斯是她的偶像。她很清楚他在1972年名人堂比赛中为钢人队完成的那个动作，被称为“完美接球”。她迫不及待地想见到他。这里情况很艰难。真的很吵，而且很多人，当他们不在调戏凯西时，就只是令人讨厌。尽管如此，她还是得到了一些登记。
I stopped to talk to a voter for a few minutes, and when I find Casey again, she's somehow rounded up eight more. Then we hit the porta-potty line, which is good for another half dozen. After that, Casey ventured into the middle of a huge crowd of mostly men, who were circled around two shirtless guys covered in white body paint and wrestling.
我停下来和一位选民聊了几分钟，当我再次找到凯西时，她已经搞定了八个。然后我们去了流动厕所的队伍，那里又搞定了半打。之后，凯西冒险进入了一大群主要是男人的中间，他们围着两个涂着白色人体彩绘、赤裸上身的家伙在摔跤。
Hug it out. Hug it out. Hug it out. Hug it out. Hug it out.
拥抱一下。拥抱一下。拥抱一下。拥抱一下。拥抱一下。
[CHEERING]
[欢呼声]
Listen. Guys, stop. Everyone, listen. We have--
听着。伙计们，停下。大家，听着。我们有——
Boo!
嘘！
--NFL-- We have NFL players--
——NFL—— 我们有NFL球员——
Boo!
嘘！
[UNINTELLIGIBLE] over at our tailgate.
[听不清] 在我们的尾门派对。
Hey, what's it for?
嘿，这是干什么的？
It's the Students for Barack Obama tailgate. We have Franco Harris, Immaculate Reception, a lot of other NFL players.
这是“巴拉克·奥巴马学生支持者”的尾门派对。我们有弗兰科·哈里斯，“完美接球”选手，还有其他许多NFL球员。
Hey, hey, did you see this thing yet?
嘿，嘿，你看到这个东西了吗？
What the fuck is this?
这他妈的是什么？
It's hilarious.
这太搞笑了。
A guy shows Casey the screen of his cellphone, which plays a little video of Barack Obama's face, which then turns into a monkey's face.
一个家伙给凯西看了他的手机屏幕，上面播放着巴拉克·奥巴马脸部的小视频，然后变成了猴子的脸。
We need to get out of here.
我们得离开这儿。
That's what we think of him here.
那就是我们这里对他的看法。
That's what we think of Obama around here, they tell her. Get the [BLEEP] out of here. We hurry away, but Casey doesn't miss a beat, on to the next group.
那就是我们这里对奥巴马的看法，他们告诉她。给老子滚出这里。我们匆忙离开，但凯西没有错过任何一个节奏，继续走向下一组人。
Hey, guys, are you all registered to vote at your current addresses? Awesome. You guys should swing by our tailgate. We're Students for Barack Obama.
嘿，伙计们，你们都用现在的地址登记投票了吗？太棒了。你们应该去我们的尾门派对。我们是“巴拉克·奥巴马学生支持者”。
Can I just talk to you for a second about what just happened back there, that incredibly racist thing he had on his phone.
我能跟你聊一秒关于刚才发生的事吗，那个他手机上显示的极其种族主义的东西。
Yes.
是的。
Does that happen to you? Do you come across that?
那常发生在你身上吗？你会遇到那种事吗？
I haven't seen anything of that magnitude before. That is very upsetting. I immediately-- I have to, for me to stay as active and positive and with the same kind of attitude that I've been having, I need to block that out for now, or else it'll just be too discouraging.
我以前没见过那种程度的事。那非常令人不安。我立刻——我必须，为了保持我一直以来的那种积极和主动的态度，我需要暂时屏蔽它，否则这会太令人沮丧了。
We rush back to the Obama tailgate so Casey can meet the NFL stars, but we're too late. They've all left.
我们冲回奥巴马的尾门派对，想让凯西见见那些NFL明星，但我们来晚了。他们全都走了。
Wait, the guy who's your idol is--
等等，那个是你的偶像的家伙是——
Franco Harris, yeah. Immaculate Reception, 1972, against the Raiders. But it's all right.
弗兰科·哈里斯，是的。1972年对阵突袭者队的“完美接球”。但没关系。
But there was--
但是有——
Oh, Casey.
哦，凯西。
You are really upset. I'm going to--
你真的很沮丧。我打算——
Casey turns away. She's sad about Franco Harris, but my guess is that's not why she's crying. She's kind of jangled right now. Registration is all she thinks about or cares about. She's devoting most of her time to more or less begging other people to care about it too. And mostly, they don't.
凯西转过身去。她因为没见到弗兰科·哈里斯而难过，但我猜那不是她哭的原因。她现在情绪有点失控。登记是她想到的或关心的全部。她把大部分时间都花在某种程度上乞求其他人也关心它。而大多数人，并不关心。
Sarah Koenig. We will hop back over to her, and to the students, as they try to make their goal in State College, in a little bit.
萨拉·科尼格。稍后，当学生们试图在州学院实现他们的目标时，我们将再次回到她身边。
There's this speech that's been making the rounds for the last month on YouTube and the political blogs and the news. It's by the secretary treasurer of the AFL-CIO, Richard Trumka. He's been traveling the country making this speech to unions. In it, he recounts a conversation that he had with a woman right here in Pennsylvania, in his hometown, a Democrat who said she couldn't bring herself to vote for Barack Obama.
过去一个月，网上和政治博客及新闻中一直在流传着一篇演讲。它是AFL-CIO秘书长理查德·特鲁姆卡发表的。他一直在全国各地向工会发表这个演讲。在演讲中，他讲述了他在宾夕法尼亚州家乡与一位女性的谈话，那是一个说自己无法投票给巴拉克·奥巴马的民主党人。
The woman tells Trumka that the reason that she can't is that he's a Muslim. Trumka tells her that's not true. She then says that it's because he won't wear a flag pin. Trumka points out that he isn't wearing a flag pin, neither is she. Finally, the woman says she feels like she just can't trust Barack Obama.
那位女士告诉特鲁姆卡，她无法投票的原因是他是穆斯林。特鲁姆卡告诉她那不是真的。她接着说是因为他不戴国旗徽章。特鲁姆卡指出他没戴国旗徽章，她也没戴。最后，那位女士说她觉得她就是无法信任巴拉克·奥巴马。
And I said, why is that? And she drops her voice a bit, and she says, because he's black. And I said, look around this town. There's no jobs here. Our kids are moving away because there's no future here. And here's a man, Barack Obama, who's going to fight for people like us, and you want to tell me that you won't vote for him because of the color of his skin? Are you out of your ever-lovin' mind, lady?
我说，为什么呢？她压低了声音，说，因为他是黑人。我说，看看这个镇。这里没有工作。我们的孩子因为这里没有未来而搬走。这里有一个人，巴拉克·奥巴马，他要为我们这样的人而战，你却要告诉我因为他的肤色而不投票给他？女士，你是不是疯了？
See, brothers and sisters--
听着，兄弟姐妹们——
[APPLAUSE]
[掌声]
--we can't tap dance around the fact that there's a lot of folks out there just like that woman. And a lot of them are good union people. They just can't get past the idea that there's something wrong with voting for a black man. Well those of us who know better can't afford to sit silently, or look the other way while it's happening.
——我们不能绕过这样一个事实，即有很多像那位女士一样的人。其中很多人是优秀的工会成员。他们就是无法克服投票给黑人有什么不对的想法。好吧，我们这些知道真相的人不能眼睁睁地看着它发生而袖手旁观，或者视而不见。
[APPLAUSE]
[掌声]
As he travels around the country making this speech to union members, Richard Trumka tells the audience, you have a responsibility to stand up about race. You have to deal with it directly. Other union leaders are saying the same thing, which is an incredible assignment to give to people. This is a subject that most people have trouble confronting and talking about honestly.
当他走遍全国向工会成员发表这一演讲时，理查德·特鲁姆卡告诉听众，你有责任在种族问题上挺身而出。你必须直接面对它。其他工会领导人也这么说，这给人们布置了一个难以置信的任务。这是大多数人在面对并诚实交谈时感到困难的主题。
There are a lot of union members in Pennsylvania. A third of all voters in 2004 came from union households, according to CNN exit polls. And we wondered if these union members were taking up the charge, talking about race. And we wondered how they did it. One of our producers, Lisa Pollak, spent the last month traveling around the state to find out.
宾夕法尼亚州有很多工会成员。根据CNN的出口民调，2004年三分之一的选民来自工会家庭。我们想知道这些工会成员是否承担起了这个责任，讨论种族问题。我们想知道他们是怎么做到的。我们的制片人之一，丽莎·波拉克，花了一个月时间走遍全州去寻找答案。
In early September, I went to a phone bank in Johnstown, Pennsylvania. And I wasn't there long, maybe 15 minutes, before I saw someone right in front of me confront the same sort of racism that Richard Trumka talked about in his speech.
九月初，我去了一个位于宾夕法尼亚州约翰斯敦的电话银行。我待的时间不长，也就15分钟，就看到有人在我的面前面对了理查德·特鲁姆卡在演讲中谈到的那种种族主义。
Hi, is this Ronnie? Hi, I'm Helen. I'm calling from the union.
嗨，是罗尼吗？嗨，我是海伦。我从工会打电话过来。
We were in a conference room at a local union headquarters. There was a big whiteboard on the wall where someone had written, smile while you're on the phone, and, be polite, even when they're not polite to you. Helen, smiling, asked the man if he'd chosen a candidate. John McCain, he said.
我们在当地一个工会总部的会议室里。墙上有一个大白板，有人写着：打电话时保持微笑，并且，要有礼貌，即使对方对你没礼貌。微笑的海伦问那个人是否选好了候选人。他说，约翰·麦凯恩。
And can I ask why? You think he's a Muslim. You're not ready for a black man. Well, he's half white.
我可以问为什么吗？你认为他是穆斯林。你没准备好要一个黑人。嗯，他是混血儿。
This was not the conversation I'd imagined when I first heard Richard Trumka give that stirring address on the need to stand up to prejudice. And I don't mean Helen backed down, because she didn't. In fact, what she did next is exactly what union organizers have told me a person in her situation should do. She didn't call the man a racist. She changed the subject from race to the issues, and started trying to persuade the man that voting for Barack Obama was simply in his best interest.
这与我第一次听到理查德·特鲁姆卡发表关于挺身而出对抗偏见的煽动性演讲时所想象的谈话不同。我不是说海伦退缩了，因为她没有。事实上，她接下来做的事情正是工会组织者告诉我的处于她这种情况的人应该做的事。她没有骂那个人是种族主义者。她把话题从种族转向了问题，并开始试图说服那个人投票给巴拉克·奥巴马纯粹符合他的最佳利益。
McCain is not union-friendly. He voted for NAFTA and CAFTA. He sides with big oil over working families, wants to privatize social security. Well, you know what, she is-- she was. She was great on our issues, and I have to tell you that, if you check out, Barack Obama's very similar, and now that she's supporting him. And especially if you're a union worker-- and Barack Obama is not a Muslim. He's a Christian.
麦凯恩不支持工会。他投票支持NAFTA和CAFTA。他站在大石油公司一边反对劳动家庭，想要私有化社会保障。好吧，你知道吗，她是——她是。她在我们的议题上表现很好，我必须告诉你，如果你去查一下，巴拉克·奥巴马非常相似，现在她支持他。特别是如果你是工会工人——而且巴拉克·奥巴马不是穆斯林。他是基督徒。
When you actually hear one of these conversations, you realize they're not always particularly eloquent or uplifting. They can be awkward and frustrating, and even a little wonky. In the end, after seven minutes on the phone with Helen, the guy who wasn't, quote, "ready to vote for a black man," had moved from John McCain to undecided.
当你真正听到这些谈话时，你会意识到它们并不总是特别雄辩或鼓舞人心。它们可能是尴尬和令人沮丧的，甚至有点怪异。最后，在与海伦通话七分钟后，那个声称“没准备好投票给黑人”的家伙，已经从约翰·麦凯恩转为未决定了。
I'll put you down for undecided, sir. Nice talking with you.
我把你记作未决定，先生。很高兴和你交谈。
And even that much progress took a lot of effort, not to mention patience and confidence, and a degree of nerve not everyone has. I can't do it, one woman, a shop steward, told me, right after she heard Trumka's speech at a training. I'd be intimidated if they said they couldn't vote for someone who's black. And I've seen even the most fearless talkers hit a wall when race comes up.
即使是这样一点进展也需要付出巨大的努力，更不用说耐心、信心和并不是每个人都拥有的勇气了。我做不到，一位女工会代表在听完特鲁姆卡的培训演讲后对我说。如果他们说不能投票给黑人，我会感到被恐吓。我甚至见过最无畏的谈话者在种族问题出现时撞到墙上。
At the same union hall in Johnstown where I met Helen, I listened to a group of guys from the Laborers Union Local 910 work a phone bank for Obama. Incidentally, if you're one of those people who still thinks the phrase, white male union member from Pennsylvania, is a euphemism for, won't vote for the black guy, you clearly haven't been to a union phone bank lately. I listened to one of them, Barry, single-handedly convert one undecided union voter after another to his side.
在约翰斯敦的同一个工会大厅里，我听了一组来自劳工工会910分会的家伙为奥巴马打匿名电话。顺便说一句，如果你是那些仍然认为“宾夕法尼亚州的白人男性工会成员”这个词是“不会投票给黑人”的委婉语的人，你显然最近没去过工会电话银行。我听了其中一个叫巴里的人，他单枪匹马地把他遇到的一个又一个犹豫不决的工会选民转化到了他这边。
Well, what's the problem with Obama? Uh-huh. That tough times are scary. So why would you want to put the same thing back in there? I would think-- My bottom line is, you know, do you want four more years of Bush in there? And that's more or less what you're going to get with McCain in there, I think. Yeah.
嗯，奥巴马有什么问题吗？嗯哼。那段艰难时期很可怕。那为什么你想把同样的东西再放进去呢？我会想——我的底线是，你知道，你想让布什再干四年吗？如果你让麦凯恩进去，差不多就是你会得到的。是的。
Put me down for Obama, the guy said. But a little later, Barry had a conversation that didn't end so well.
把我记作奥巴马的支持者，那个人说。但过了一会儿，巴里进行了一次结果并不好的谈话。
I called a member, and I asked him who he was going to vote for. And he said, not Obama. And I said, why is that? And he said, I'm prejudiced. And how do I argue with that? You know?
我打电话给一个会员，问他打算投票给谁。他说，不是奥巴马。我说，为什么呢？他说，我有偏见。我该怎么反驳呢？你知道吗？
What'd you say?
你说了什么？
I didn't say anything. I said, OK, thank you. I don't think you're going to talk him out of it. I don't think I would. If I don't know them, I don't think they're going to listen to me.
我什么都没说。我说，好的，谢谢。我不认为你能说服他改变主意。我不认为我会。如果我不认识他们，我认为他们不会听我的。
They won't listen to you, not at all.
他们不会听你的，一点也不会。
Ray, another guy working the phones, chimes in.
雷，另一个在电话工作的人插话道。
They're not afraid to tell you that, so they're not going to change. Just like an old woman with abortion issues, she's not going to change. A gun nut's the same way. He ain't going to change. Those are three issues right now you aren't going to change people.
他们不害怕告诉你这一点，所以他们不会改变。就像一个在堕胎问题上有老观念的女人，她是不会改变的。拥枪狂也一样。他是不会改变的。这三个议题是你现在没法改变人们的。
So, this idea that, OK, members have to be taking on the race issue with members, unrealistic?
所以，这种“会员必须与会员讨论种族议题”的想法，是不现实的？
I mean, you could try, but you're not going to get them. They're not going to turn over because you say, hey, this is the way to vote. They're going to say, hey, this is what I feel in my heart and this is what I'm sticking with.
我的意思是，你可以尝试，但你不会争取到他们。他们不会因为你说“嘿，这是投票的方式”而倒戈。他们会说，“嘿，这是我心里的感受，我坚持这一点。”
I have no idea how many people have been in Ray or Barry or Helen's shoes, confronted by somebody bold enough to admit, with little or no coaxing, that the problem with Obama is his race. I've talked to people who say they've never had this happen, and people who say they've heard it a lot.
我不知道有多少人像雷、巴里或海伦那样，面对一个敢于在几乎没有劝说的情况下承认奥巴马的问题在于种族的家伙。我谈过一些人，他们说从未遇到过这种情况，也谈过一些人，他们说他们听过很多次。
A union organizer who's traveled the state told me that one in 10 voters he talked to said something to his face about Obama's skin color, only they don't always put it in such civilized terms. Mike Harms, a bus operator with the Amalgamated Transit Union Local 85 in Pittsburgh, saw this firsthand while canvassing recently.
一位走遍该州的工会组织者告诉我，他谈话的选民中十分之一的人当面提到了奥巴马的肤色，只是他们不总是用那么文明的措辞。迈克·哈姆斯，匹兹堡联合公交工会85分会的公交车操作员，最近在拉票时亲眼看到了这一点。
I had a guy, he actually came right out and told me, I ain't voting for no effin' N-word. To tell you the truth, the way he said it, I mean, my jaw actually dropped a little bit. So yeah, the first thing I countered with was, well, you see what's going on with the economy, if George Bush and/or John McCain had their way, they'd privatize social security, and where would you be now? And then we hit on a couple pension issues and some health care stuff.
我有个家伙，他居然直接告诉我，我不会投票给任何该死的黑鬼。说实话，他说这话的方式，我的下巴真的有点惊掉了。所以是的，我反驳的第一件事是，嗯，你看到经济发生了什么吗，如果乔治·布什和/或约翰·麦凯恩得逞，他们会私有化社会保障，那你现在会在哪里？然后我们谈了一些养老金问题和一些医疗保健的东西。
And he listened?
他听了吗？
Oh yeah, absolutely, absolutely. He actually invited me into his home.
哦，当然，当然。他甚至邀请我进了他的家。
Really?
真的吗？
Yeah, yeah. So, after about 15 or 20 minutes of talking issues with him, he sort of came around. Now, he told me that he was going to think about it. I don't think that it actually it 100% changed his mind, but when I first approached the door, he was absolutely 100% he wasn't voting for a black person.
是的，是的。所以，在和他谈了大约15或20分钟问题后，他有点改变了态度。现在，他告诉我他会考虑一下。我不认为它真的100%改变了他的主意，但当我第一次走到门口时，他是绝对100%不投黑人的。
We in this room are not going to solve the race issue in America. This is a 200-year-old wound with a 60-year scab on it, right?
我们在这个房间里不会解决美国的种族问题。这是一个有着60年结痂的200年伤口，对吧？
That's Michael Fedor, a union organizer in central Pennsylvania, teaching a training session I attended in Johnstown last month. Michael's message to union members was utterly practical: some people's minds can't be changed no matter what you tell them, and the best way to sway the others is with the facts. He cited research showing that the more union members know about Obama's record and positions, the more they like him.
那是迈克尔·费多尔，宾夕法尼亚州中部的一位工会组织者，在上个月我在约翰斯敦参加的一个培训会议上说的话。迈克尔给工会成员的信息是非常实际的：无论你怎么说，有些人的想法是无法改变的，而说服其他人的最好方法是用事实。他引用研究表明，工会成员对奥巴马的记录和立场了解越多，他们就越喜欢他。
Unions have gone to a lot of effort and expense this year to get that message out, with all sorts of mailings and voter guides and videos that emphasize Obama's support for labor and the working class. Like this one from the building and construction trades.
工会今年花了很多精力和费用来传达这个信息，通过各种邮件、选民指南和视频，强调奥巴马对劳工和工人阶级的支持。就像这个来自建筑工会的视频。
It's time we had a president who didn't choke saying the word "union." It's not that hard. Union. See? Nothing happens. Union. It's all right.
是时候我们有一位总统，在说“工会”这个词时不会噎住了。这并不难。工会。你看？什么都没发生。工会。没关系。
You see, brothers and sisters, there's not a single good reason for any worker, especially any union member, to vote against Barack Obama. There's only one really bad reason to vote against him, because he's not white.
你看，兄弟姐妹们，没有任何一个好理由让工人，尤其是工会成员，投票反对巴拉克·奥巴马。只有一个非常糟糕的理由投反对票，因为他不是白人。
This is a nonpartisan commercial from the American Federation of Government Employees.
这是一个来自美国政府雇员联合会的无党派商业广告。
There are 100 good reasons for how you vote this year, and only one bad reason: prejudice. Let's talk about the real issues.
今年你有100个好理由决定如何投票，只有一个坏理由：偏见。让我们谈谈真正的问题。
This is a training tape from the United Steelworkers.
这是来自钢铁工人联合会的培训录像带。
If you closed your eyes and listen to Barack Obama, you walk away and you say, that's my guy. 98% voting record for labor on labor's issues. That's why we back him. John McCain, 15%.
如果你闭上眼睛听巴拉克·奥巴马说话，你走开时会说，那家伙是我的菜。98%的投票记录是为劳工利益投的。这就是我们支持他的原因。约翰·麦凯恩，15%。
But for all the statistics and talking points, what I realized, listening to union members in Pennsylvania, is that when you're actually face to face with people who say they won't vote for your candidate because he's black, you're on your own. You have to muddle through and figure out your own way to do it, to navigate this touchy emotional subject, with people whose beliefs may never have been challenged before.
但对于所有的数据和谈话要点，我意识到，在宾夕法尼亚州听工会成员说话时，当你真正面对面接触那些说因为他是黑人而不投给你的候选人的人时，你是孤军奋战。你必须设法去搞清楚自己处理它的方式，去驾驭这个敏感的情绪化主题，与那些信念可能从未受到挑战的人交谈。
And union members are doing this. Some have had so much practice that now they've got their response lines down cold, their own favorite combinations of issues and zingers. They try everything from, if you were drowning, wouldn't you let a black guy save you? To, white guys have messed this country up plenty, so why not give a black man a chance? I heard one union official quote a Chris Rock line, "was America ready for a black baseball player in the '40s? No, but Jackie Robinson was better than everyone."
工会成员正在这样做。有些人练习得太多，现在他们已经熟练掌握了回应台词，他们自己喜爱的议题和金句组合。他们尝试各种方法，从“如果你快淹死了，难道不会让黑人救你吗？”到“白人已经把这个国家搞得一团糟了，为什么不给黑人一个机会？”我听到一位工会官员引用克里斯·洛克的台词：“美国为40年代的黑人棒球运动员做好准备了吗？没有，但杰基·罗宾逊比任何人都强。”
And then there was the union local president, who said he actually got out a globe to prove to an elderly relative that no less a revered figure than Jesus must have been black. Here he is, Wendell Young IV, explaining to members of the United Food and Commercial Workers Local 1776, how he made that argument.
还有工会地方分会主席，他说他真的拿出了一个地球仪，向一位年长的亲戚证明，耶稣这样受人尊敬的人物一定是黑人。他就是温德尔·杨四世，向食品和商业工人联合工会1776分会的成员解释他是如何提出那个论点的。
It's OK for God to send a black Jesus to save your ass, but it's not OK to vote for a guy for president who's going to make sure you have health care, protect your pension, do those other things. And by the way, if I'm wrong, who's going to be able to prove it? But here's one thing, if you're a Christian and you believe in the teachings of Christ, Christ wouldn't have cared whether he was black. Wouldn't have cared.
上帝派一个黑人耶稣来救你的屁股是可以的，但投票给一个将确保你有医疗保健、保护你的养老金、做那些其他事情的总统候选人就不行。顺便说一句，如果我错了，谁能证明它？但有一件事，如果你是基督徒并且信仰基督的教导，基督才不会在乎他是不是黑人。才不会在乎。
[APPLAUSE]
[掌声]
A couple people even told me that, as a last ditch effort, when they can't change the subject to the issues because race is the voter's only issue, they'll ask the person to please consider not voting for a president at all. The most intense conversations I heard about weren't between strangers on a phone line or a front porch, but face to face between coworkers and friends.
甚至有几个人告诉我，作为最后的努力，当他们无法将话题转向议题，因为种族是选民唯一的议题时，他们会请求那个人请考虑根本不去投票。我听说的最激烈的关于谈话的并不是陌生人在电话线或前门廊上的，而是同事和朋友之间的面对面交流。
In my search for people willing to share their stories from the field, I was introduced to a man named Dan, who's not from Pennsylvania but from Maryland, where he's in the Steamfitters Union. He told me about a conversation he had with a friend about the election.
在我寻找愿意分享他们在前线故事的人时，我被介绍给了一个叫丹的男人，他不是宾夕法尼亚州的，而是马里兰州的，他在蒸汽管道工工会。他告诉我他关于选举与朋友的一次谈话。
You know, I asked him, I say, dude, what about Barack Obama? You know what I mean? He's a union guy. You're a union guy. You've kind of got to help us out here. And Mike's going, well I'm not voting for this black guy.
你知道，我问他，我说，哥们，巴拉克·奥巴马怎么样？你明白吗？他是工会人。你是工会人。你得帮我们一把。迈克说，嗯，我不投那个黑人。
And the specifics were that he'd had problems. He's got young daughters, and they go to school, and he picks them up at the bus stop and he sees them playing with a lot of blacks. And that bothers him. And I said, Mike, dude, it's-- you know, he's just a racist. I mean, it's terrible.
细节是他遇到过问题。他有年幼的女儿，她们去上学，他在公共汽车站接她们，他看到她们和很多黑人玩。这困扰着他。我说，迈克，哥们，它是——你知道，他只是个种族主义者。我的意思是，这太可怕了。
And do you remember what you said?
你还记得你说了什么吗？
Well, yeah. Well, Mike, I said, you've got to get past this. I said, this is crazy. If you let race get in the way of what's going to happen with your future, I said, you're just, you're being an idiot about it. And I was starting to get a little bit angry, because I've known this guy for several years, and I never knew the way that he felt. And it was offensive to me, the way that he talked about it.
好吧，是的。我说，迈克，你得克服这个。我说，这太疯狂了。如果你让种族阻碍了你未来的发展，我说，你是白痴。我开始有点生气了，因为我认识这家伙好几年了，我从来不知道他有这种感觉。以他的谈话方式，这对我来说是冒犯性的。
And you told him so.
你告诉他了？
Absolutely, absolutely. And he goes, well, dude, that's the way it is. You live your life, you see things the way you do and I see things the way I do. I said, yeah, but Mike, you've got to get past this not only for this election but with your life. I mean, you know, you work with black guys, with several people that we know, and you never have a problem with them.
绝对，绝对。他说，好吧，哥们，事实就是这样。你过你的生活，你以你的方式看事情，我以我的方式看。我说，是的，但是迈克，你不仅为了这次选举，而且为了你的生活，你得克服这个。我的意思是，你知道，你和黑人一起工作，和我们认识的几个人一起，你从来没有和他们出过问题。
And he goes, well, on the job I've got to work with them. I said, well, I see you, you sit there and eat lunch with them, you joke around, and play around. That's not work. You do that, you don't dislike those guys.
他说，嗯，他说，在工作中我得和他们共事。我说，好吧，我看见你，你坐在那儿和他们一起吃午饭，开玩笑，一起玩。那不是工作。你做了，你不讨厌那些家伙。
He goes, well, he goes, I'll look at the information and everything, and we can talk about this later. But he goes, I just don't think I'm going to do it. I'm just not going to do it. I'm not going to have a black man in there. He said, the next thing you know, you'll have Jesse Jackson as secretary of state and Al Sharpton in the Department of the Treasury. He thinks that Barack Obama's going to flood all his cabinets with all these black radicals.
他说，嗯，他说，我会看信息和所有东西，以后我们再谈这个。但他说，我只是认为我不会那样做。我就是不会。我不会让黑人进去。他说，接下来你知道的，你会有杰西·杰克逊当国务卿，阿尔·夏普顿当财政部长。他认为巴拉克·奥巴马会用那些黑人激进分子填满他的所有内阁。
He told you that?
他那样告诉你？
Oh, absolutely, yes. I said, come on, Mike. You can't be serious. This is the president of the United-- This is going to be the president of the United States. It's not a game. And he goes, well, that's the way I feel about it. And I said, well, I'm sorry to hear you say that, Mike.
哦，绝对，是的。我说，拜托，迈克。你不可能认真的。这是美国总统——这会是美国总统。这不是游戏。他说，嗯，这就是我的感受。我说，好吧，很抱歉听到你这么说，迈克。
So you didn't get anywhere with him?
所以你没跟他谈成？
No, absolutely no. No, not at all. I kind of wish I hadn't of gotten into this the way that I have, because it's shown me sides of people that I've worked with and known for many years that I had no idea were like this. And it hurts me, because these people were my-- are my friends. And to finally-- I feel betrayed, honestly.
不，绝对没有。不，一点都没有。我有点希望我没有以这种方式陷入其中，因为它向我展示了我共事和认识多年的人们的另一面，我根本不知道他们是这样的。这伤害了我，因为这些人曾经是我的——是我的朋友。最终——坦白说，我觉得被背叛了。
I would end the story there, were it not for all the people who've insisted to me, that as disappointing as it can be, speaking up is always worth it. One of those people is John Cunnard, a machine operator and president of United Steelworkers Local 1211, in Beaver County, Pennsylvania. He says he's had a lot of these conversations with his members the past few months. He's got his own favorite tactics and comebacks. And he's seen them work.
如果不是所有坚持对我这样说的人，我就会结束这个故事，即尽管它可能令人失望，但大声说出来总是值得的。其中之一是约翰·卡纳德，机器操作员和钢铁工人联合会宾夕法尼亚州比弗县1211分会主席。他说过去几个月他和他的会员们进行了很多这种谈话。他有他自己最喜欢的策略和反击。而且他见过它们奏效。
I've got a few people down there that I thought would never go for Obama, but they're on my side. They're pushing Obama.
我那里有几个人，我以为他们永远不会支持奥巴马，但他们站在我这边。他们在推动奥巴马。
John, of all people, should know voters can change. During the Pennsylvania primary, he was a fierce supporter of Hillary Clinton. But when Obama got the nomination, John joined the ranks of the undecided, worried about Obama's lack of experience, even though he knew that Hillary and Obama had much more in common than Hillary and McCain. To my surprise, John said he still might be undecided if he hadn't gone to a union meeting and heard none other than Richard Trumka bring up the subject of race.
约翰应该最清楚选民是可以改变的。在宾夕法尼亚州初选期间，他是希拉里·克林顿的坚定支持者。但当奥巴马获得提名时，约翰加入了未决定者的行列，担心奥巴马缺乏经验，尽管他知道希拉里和奥巴马的共同点远多于希拉里和麦凯恩。令我惊讶的是，约翰说如果他没有去参加工会会议并听到理查德·特鲁姆卡本人提出种族话题，他可能还是未决定的。
When he got up there and started talking, there was no doubt in your mind that he was talking black and white, and he wanted you to think about whether you're going to vote for this guy or not vote for him because he's black. And I started thinking about it. I'm sitting there thinking, well, damn, I really don't discriminate against anybody, but who knows.
当他站起来开始说话时，你心里毫无疑问他在谈论黑人和白人，他想让你考虑你是要投票给这个家伙还是因为他是黑人而不投给他。我开始思考它。我坐在那儿想，好吧，该死，我真的没有歧视任何人，但谁知道呢。
But it made me look at the whole situation. And eliminating color out of it, which one of these two would I rather have as president? So once I eliminated color, then it was Obama. Well, I just sat there and said, well, yeah, you're right. See, so a lot of people don't think about it, because everybody sits there and says, not me.
但这让我审视了整个情况。剔除肤色，这两个人中我宁愿选谁当总统？所以一旦我剔除了肤色，那么就是奥巴马了。好吧，我只是坐在那儿说，好吧，是的，你是对的。看，所以很多人没想过，因为每个人坐在那儿都说，不是我。
John told me he's never put as much effort into pushing a candidate as he has this year. And I get the feeling that goes for a lot of union members in Pennsylvania. According to polling numbers from the AFL-CIO, Obama's lead over McCain among union households in Pennsylvania rose 11 points between mid-August and early October. That poll gave McCain 27% of those voters, and Obama, 63%.
约翰告诉我，他从未像今年这样在推动候选人身上投入那么多精力。我感觉在宾夕法尼亚州的很多工会成员也是如此。根据AFL-CIO的民调数字，奥巴马在宾夕法尼亚州工会家庭中对麦凯恩的领先优势在8月中旬到10月初之间上升了11个百分点。那项民调给予麦凯恩27%的选民，奥巴马63%。
Lisa Pollak. Coming up, we take another turn around the state, and along the way we checked back in with the college students and the Democrats for McCain that we heard from earlier. That's in a minute, from Chicago Public Radio and Public Radio International, when our program continues.
丽莎·波拉克。接下来，我们将再次转过这个州，沿途我们查看了我们之前听到的大学生和“支持麦凯恩的民主党人”的情况。那是片刻之后，来自芝加哥公共广播电台和国际公共广播电台，当我们的节目继续时。
It's This American Life . I'm Ira Glass. Today, with a week to go before election day, we are spending the hour in one of the hottest battleground states this year, Pennsylvania, to see how the ground war is playing out there. Earlier in this hour, we heard college students who were struggling to make their voter registration goal for Barack Obama. That goal was 21,000 new student voters, and it was not going well.
这是《This American Life》。我是艾拉·格拉斯。今天，距离选举日还有一周，我们这一个小时是在今年最热门的战场州之一，宾夕法尼亚州，看看地面战在那里是如何展开的。在这个小时早些时候，我们听到了那些努力为巴拉克·奥巴马实现选民登记目标的大学生。那个目标是21000名新学生选民，进展并不顺利。
Sarah Koenig picks up the action where we left off, with one of the volunteers she's following, one who is incredibly skilled at getting registrations, Casey Miller.
萨拉·科尼格接着我们离开的地方，与她追踪的志愿者之一，一个在获取登记方面非常有技巧的人，凯西·米勒。
Casey basically lives in the Obama office. She's earned her own corner there. She's got a little desk with a vase of dying flowers on it, sent by her mother for her birthday. And there's her computer. Four backpacks are lying around, cigarettes, nail polish. She keeps a curling iron in the bathroom.
凯西基本上住在奥巴马办公室。她在那儿赢得了属于她自己的角落。她有一个小桌子，上面有一束母亲为她生日寄来的正在凋谢的花。还有她的电脑。四周围着四个背包，香烟，指甲油。她在浴室里放了一个卷发棒。
She dropped three of her six mechanical engineering classes to do this, and she's way behind on the ones she didn't drop. She didn't plan on any of this. She's not someone who ever worked on campaigns before, but she took it pretty hard when John Kerry lost.
她为了做这个放弃了六门机械工程课中的三门，而且她没放弃的那些课落后很多。她没计划任何这一切。她以前从没做过竞选工作，但约翰·克里输掉时她受了很大打击。
I cried when Bush won in '04.
布什在04年赢的时候我哭了。
Oh, you did?
哦，你哭了？
Oh yeah, yeah, all night. I just balled my eyes out. It was just awful. I called my mom crying. I couldn't believe it. And I lost a lot of faith in this country when we reelected him. I don't understand how.
哦，是的，是的，整晚。我只是泪流满面。这太可怕了。我哭着打电话给我妈。我不敢相信。当我们再次选他时，我对这个国家失去了很多信心。我不明白是怎么回事。
The fact that we made the same mistake twice, just, that's what basically turned me off from the whole politics thing. I kind of threw myself into engineering, lived in the bubble of Penn State, and really didn't worry about anything outside of school and my social life and whatever.
我们两次犯了同样的错误这个事实，这就是基本上让我对整个政治事情反感的原因。我把自己投身于工程，生活在宾州州立的泡沫中，并没有担心学校、社交生活和任何其他事情之外的任何事情。
And then, as things got progressively worse, that's when I decided, yeah, I want to start volunteering with the Obama campaign. It was probably June when I decided that I wanted to do that. I came in, in July, and haven't left.
然后，随着情况逐渐变糟，我决定，是的，我想开始为奥巴马竞选团队做志愿者。大概是六月我决定要那样做的。我七月进来，就没离开过。
Six days before the registration deadline, the campaign throws a party for all the volunteers. Outside the room, the registration thermometer is at about 14,000, 2/3 of the way toward their goal. There's a DJ, but people are so tired and rundown, no one dances, except, briefly, Casey.
距离登记截止日期还有六天，竞选团队为所有志愿者开了个派对。房间外面，登记温度计在大约14000，距离他们的目标还有2/3。有DJ，但人们太累了，没人跳舞，除了凯西短暂地跳了一下。
Then, as some sort of scared straight motivation tool, they play them what passes for a campaign horror movie. It's a fake video of NBC news anchor Tom Brokaw announcing a McCain victory. Afterwards, stunned silence. It seems like the next logical thing is for everyone to burst into tears, but they quickly move on.
然后，作为某种“恐惧改变”的动力工具，他们播放了被当作竞选恐怖电影的东西。这是NBC新闻主播汤姆·布罗考宣布麦凯恩获胜的假视频。事后，惊人的沉默。似乎下一件逻辑上的事情是每个人都大哭一场，但他们很快转移话题。
Next up is Jay Paterno, son of Penn State football coach slash legend, Joe Paterno. Paterno the son is the team's quarterback coach, and he brings three football players along, two of them had to be registered on the spot. Meanwhile, he delivers a halftime locker room pep talk to roughly 50 kids listening.
接下来是杰伊·帕特诺，宾州州立橄榄球教练/传奇人物乔·帕特诺的儿子。儿子帕特诺是球队的四分卫教练，他带来了三个橄榄球运动员，其中两个必须当场登记。同时，他给大约50个听着的孩子做了一次半场更衣室动员演讲。
You've got six days left. And this is the toughest part of the election, guys. And where you guys are right now is you're in the middle of preseason practice, and preseason practice, quite frankly, sucks. Am I lying? No. It sucks. OK? Because it's all you do. And how good a football team we are in the fall depends on what we do in preseason practice. And how much Obama wins this thing by is going to be determined by what you guys do the next couple of weeks.
你们还剩六天。这是选举中最艰难的部分，伙计们。你们现在所在的位置是季前赛练习中，而季前赛练习坦率地说，烂透了。我在撒谎吗？没有。烂透了。好吧？因为这就是你所做的一切。我们在秋季能成为一支多好的球队取决于我们在季前赛练习中做了什么。奥巴马赢得多少取决于你们接下来几周做了什么。
His message is, don't stop, don't relax. And for the next six days, no one does. The workers are put in competition with each other. Prizes are announced. And everyone starts fighting everyone else to boost their own numbers. People are encroaching on other people's turf. Some registrations are getting double counted. Someone is spotted swiping completed forms from another organization's drop box.
他的意思是，别停下，别放松。在接下来的六天里，没人放松。工人们之间展开了竞争。公布了奖品。每个人都开始和别人争夺以提高自己的数字。人们侵占了别人的地盘。一些登记被重复计算了。有人被发现从另一个组织的收集箱里窃取已填写的表格。
But, of course, this 11th-hour frenzy is choreographed by the campaign, because the last thing anyone wants at the end of all this is to have to admit that they didn't meet their goal. Though, in reality, the 21,000 goal has a cushion built in. It's more than Obama needs, but only people at the very top of the campaign know how much more.
但是，当然，这种最后时刻的疯狂是由竞选团队编排的，因为在这一切结束时，没人想承认他们没达到目标。尽管实际上，21000的目标内含缓冲。这比奥巴马需要的更多，但只有竞选团队最高层的人才知道多了多少。
It's Sunday night, October 5, the night before the deadline. There's a party atmosphere in the campaign office, except everyone at the party is seriously sleep deprived, and also, working. Zack Zabel, the head of Students for Barack Obama, comes in with some forms.
是周日晚上，10月5日，截止日期前一天。竞选办公室有派对氛围，除了派对上的每个人都严重睡眠不足，而且还在工作。“巴拉克·奥巴马学生支持者”负责人扎克·扎贝尔带着一些表格进来了。
How many did you get?
你搞到了多少？
Seven, but that's like the fourth time I've done it today.
七个，但这大概是我今天第四次做这个了。
You seem really, really tired.
你看起来真的很累。
I'm all right. We should actually go out and do it on the streets right now, register voters.
我没事。我们现在应该出去在街上做这个，登记选民。
Keep going?
继续？
Yeah. We only have like 15 hours.
是的。我们只有大概15个小时了。
If you listen closely, you can hear Ben Flatgard, the regional director, singing from his office. He's doing who knows what on his computer, coughing. Then Casey comes in a few minutes before midnight. She's been at some student apartment buildings, and now she's delivering her forms for the daily count.
如果你仔细听，你可以听到区域主任本·弗拉特加德在他的办公室里唱歌。他在他的电脑上做着天知道什么，咳嗽着。然后凯西在午夜前几分钟进来。她一直在一些学生公寓楼，现在她在交付表格供每日统计。
How many did you get?
你搞到了多少？
I just brought back 32. Tom and I, yeah, Tom's in. He--
我刚带回来32个。汤姆和我，是的，汤姆进来了。他——
It's their best Sunday yet, but Casey's not comforted by this milestone.
这是他们表现最好的周日，但凯西并没有被这个里程碑安慰到。
It's exciting. I mean, I'm really-- it's a little concerning because we registered 562 people today. Why weren't they registered before? Are there still people that are going to be not registered? So, I'm just going to be the last person on the streets.
这很令人兴奋。我的意思是，我真的很——这有点令人担忧，因为我们今天登记了562个人。为什么他们以前没登记？还有人不会被登记吗？所以，我只是要成为街上最后一个人。
Casey goes back out to keep registering. It's past midnight now. She heads to a crowded below-ground bar where there's a live band playing. It's so loud I can barely record.
凯西回到外面继续登记。现在已经过了午夜。她前往一家拥挤的地下酒吧，那里有现场乐队演奏。太吵了，我几乎没法录音。
Are are you all registered to vote at your current address?
你们都用现在的地址登记投票了吗？
I assume she's going to want to leave, since no one can hear a word she's saying, but she stays and she gets 12 registrations.
我想她会想要离开，因为没人能听到她在说什么，但她留下来并获得了12个登记。
Are you registered to vote at your current State College address? Are you registered to vote at your current State College address?
你们用现在的州学院地址登记投票了吗？你们用现在的州学院地址登记投票了吗？
In the end, they didn't make their 21,000 goal, but they were close. They registered 16,904 students. And if you add in all the other groups, MoveOn, SEIU, Sierra Club, over 23,600 people were registered in the county.
最终，他们没完成21000的目标，但很接近。他们登记了16904名学生。如果你加上所有其他团体，MoveOn，SEIU，塞拉俱乐部，超过23600人在该县登记。
Casey, of course, registered more voters than anybody else, and won a prize: football tickets. As a result of all this work, Centre County now has over 100,000 voters for the first time ever. And also for the first time, Democrats outnumber Republicans in the county by 5,000 registrations.
凯西当然比任何人都登记了更多选民，并赢得了奖品：橄榄球票。由于所有这些工作，中央县有史以来第一次拥有超过100000名选民。而且也是第一次，该县民主党人的登记人数比共和党人多5000。
Dianne Gregg, chairwoman of the County Democrats, is pretty happy. Her county, she says, is now in a position to have an enormous impact on the outcome of this election. Dianne keeps a poster of James Carville in her office to reminder of his infamous comment, that Pennsylvania is Philadelphia and Pittsburgh and Alabama in between. Her goal, she said, is to make Carville regret that quote.
县民主党主席黛安·格雷格很高兴。她说，她的县现在处于一个可以对这次选举结果产生巨大影响的位置。黛安在她的办公室里挂着詹姆斯·卡维尔的海报，提醒他的那句名言：宾夕法尼亚州是费城和匹兹堡，中间夹着阿拉巴马。她说，她的目标是让卡维尔后悔那句话。
Sarah Koenig. And, before we go, let's take one last trip around the state, and turn from Obama volunteers to McCain volunteers. Back at the beginning of this hour, we were in Scranton with our producer Nancy Updike, and the group, Democrats for McCain.
萨拉·科尼格。在我们要走之前，让我们最后一次在这个州转转，从奥巴马志愿者转向麦凯恩志愿者。在这个小时开始时，我们和我们的制片人南希·厄普代克在斯克兰顿，以及那个团体，“支持麦凯恩的民主党人”。
If you remember, that group was going door to door, having remarkable success in nudging Democrats into the Republican column. Now we return to Scranton.
如果你还记得，那个团体正挨家挨户，在促使民主党人进入共和党阵营方面取得了显著的成功。现在我们回到斯克兰顿。
[INTERPOSING VOICES]
[交叉的人声]
The Democrats for McCain office in Scranton is run by people who give serious chunks of their lives in service to others. One woman who's been a foster parent for 22 years, another, covered in paint, who came to the McCain office straight from her stint at Habitat for Humanity, and Judy O'Connor, a 59-year-old single mother of three on a fixed income, who pared her life down to a financial minimum to help her son, a fireman and military veteran, achieve his dream of becoming a policeman. All of them lifelong Democrats, never voted for a Republican presidential candidate in their lives.
斯克兰顿的“支持麦凯恩的民主党人”办公室由那些为他人服务而奉献了生命重要部分的人运作。一位做了22年寄养父母的女性，另一位身上沾满油漆、直接从栖息地服务中心赶到麦凯恩办公室的女性，以及朱迪·奥康纳，一位靠固定收入生活的59岁单身母亲，她将自己的生活缩减到财务最低限度，以帮助她的儿子（一名消防员和军人退伍军人）实现他成为警察的梦想。他们都是终身民主党人，一生从未投票给共和党总统候选人。
We were staunch Hillary Clinton supporters. We worked Hillary's campaign. We traveled to other states with Hillary.
我们是希拉里·克林顿的坚定支持者。我们为希拉里的竞选工作。我们和希拉里去了其他州。
This is Judy O'Connor.
这是朱迪·奥康纳。
Matter of fact, we went to the DNC meeting in Washington, DC, and that's when our party, Nancy Pelosi, Howard Dean, and the DNC, what we say, threw Hillary under the bus.
事实上，我们去了华盛顿特区的DNC会议，那就是当我们的党，南希·佩洛西，霍华德·迪恩和DNC，我们所说的，把希拉里扔到巴士下的时候。
For Judy and everyone else here, the primary battle was not a tough fight with equally questionable maneuvers on both sides. Chris and others at the office talked about personally seeing Obama supporters at caucuses, especially Texas, keeping Hillary supporters out of caucus rooms, shouting at them, preventing them from bringing in Hillary signs, all of which, not surprisingly, they say is more egregious than any tactics used by the Clinton campaign.
对于朱迪和这里的所有人来说，初选并不是一场双方都有同样可疑策略的艰难斗争。克里斯和办公室里的其他人谈到亲眼看到奥巴马在核心小组的支持者，特别是在得克萨斯州，把希拉里的支持者挡在核心小组会议室外，对他们大喊大叫，阻止他们带入希拉里的竞选标志，所有这些，不出所料，他们说比克林顿阵营使用的任何策略都更恶劣。
Challenges were filed at the Texas State Convention, but the relative unethicalness and, more important, the legality of what Chris and others saw, is hard to evaluate in the absence of a lawsuit, and no lawsuit charging caucus fraud by the Obama campaign has been filed nationally or in Texas.
在得克萨斯州代表大会上提出了质疑，但相对不道德，更重要的是，克里斯和别人看到的合法性，在没有诉讼的情况下很难评估，而且全国或得克萨斯州没有提出任何指控奥巴马竞选团队核心小组欺诈的诉讼。
The question I kept asking Judy and the others was, how does a person go from supporting a pro-choice candidate who gets a grade of 100 from unions and wants to raise the capital gains tax, to a pro-life candidate who gets a zero from unions and wants to cut the capital gains tax? Everyone had his or her own answer, but no answer went without an enraged retelling of the primary fight, especially the day the Democratic National Committee divided up the delegates from Michigan and Florida, a compromise using debatable math and logic that seemed to a lot of people not just unfair but undemocratic.
我一直问朱迪和其他人的问题是，一个人如何从支持一个获得工会100分、想要提高资本利得税的亲选择候选人，转变为一个获得工会0分、想要削减资本利得税的亲生命候选人？每个人都有自己的答案，但没有任何答案是没有对初选斗争的愤怒重述的，特别是民主党全国委员会分割密歇根州和佛罗里达州代表的那一天，那是一个使用可辩论的数学和逻辑的妥协，对很多人来说，那不仅是不公平的，而且是不民主的。
And we found ourselves having to decide between the two candidates left. And Hillary Clinton said, let's compare resumes, and that's exactly what we did. We compared Hillary's with John McCain. It was very impressive. We looked at Obama's and there was nothing there. I mean, he was in, what, in the Senate 143 days, and the rest of the time he spent on his campaign, working his campaign.
我们发现自己必须在剩下的两个候选人之间做决定。希拉里·克林顿说，让我们比较简历，这正是我们所做的。我们将希拉里的与约翰·麦凯恩的进行了比较。那非常令人印象深刻。我们看了奥巴马的，里面什么都没有。我的意思是，他在参议院待了什么，143天，剩下的时间他都花在他的竞选活动上，运作他的竞选活动。
So, I mean, there isn't experience there. I mean, even when I watch John McCain on TV, whenever he's speaking, I honestly, honestly can say I trust him and I feel the man is genuine. I truly feel he's genuine. I have tried. I'm not going to say, as a Democrat, I'm not going to say that I haven't tried to listen to Obama and be open-minded. I've tried. I do not, I do not, less and less do I trust him.
所以，我的意思是，那里没有经验。我的意思是，即使我在电视上看着约翰·麦凯恩，无论他什么时候发言，我可以诚实地，诚实地说我信任他，我觉得这个人是真诚的。我真心觉得他是真诚的。我试过了。我不是说，作为一个民主党人，我不是说我没试过听奥巴马的话并思想开放。我试过了。我没有，我没有，我越来越不信任他。
And I'm worried. I'm very worried for our country if he gets elected.
我很担心。如果他当选，我很为我们的国家担心。
This was a theme with everyone I talked to. I like John McCain, but more than that, I'm worried about Obama, worse than worried, scared.
这是我和每个人谈话的一个主题。我喜欢约翰·麦凯恩，但除此之外，我很担心奥巴马，比担心更糟糕，害怕。
In four days, I heard a lot of fear and some outlandish theories, that George Soros orchestrated the global financial crisis to give Obama a boost in the election, that Palestinian professor Rashid Khalidi secretly paid for Obama's Harvard education, possibly related to a terror financing scheme, that Obama is a crypto-Marxist, a socialist who will somehow take over the world economy, and most spectacularly, Judy met someone on the campaign trail named Larry Sinclair, a man with a 27-year criminal record, a 16-year prison stint for forgery, and 13 aliases, who's been going around saying Obama is a homosexual, a crack cocaine user, and possibly, a murderer.
四天里，我听到了很多恐惧和一些离奇的理论，乔治·索罗斯策划了全球金融危机以给奥巴马在选举中提供动力，巴勒斯坦教授拉希德·哈利迪秘密支付了奥巴马的哈佛教育费，可能与恐怖融资计划有关，奥巴马是一个加密马克思主义者，一个会以某种方式接管世界经济的社会主义者，而最引人注目的是，朱迪在竞选路上遇到了一个叫拉里·辛克莱的人，一个有27年犯罪记录、16年伪造罪监狱服刑史和13个别名的人，他一直到处说奥巴马是同性恋、快克可卡因使用者，而且可能还是个凶手。
Do you believe it?
你相信吗？
I don't know what to-- you know, I want to believe in my country. I want to believe in the people who want to be in our government. But did I question in my mind? Yes, I did. And when I went home, I got back on the internet and researched a little bit more, and everything that Larry Sinclair said to us was true.
我不知道——你知道，我想相信我的国家。我想相信那些想在我们政府任职的人。但在我心里质疑过吗？是的，我质疑过。当我回家时，我上了互联网做了更多的研究，拉里·辛克莱告诉我们的一切都是真的。
Was true according to other websites.
根据其他网站是真的。
To Larry Sinclair and other people.
对拉里·辛克莱和其他人是真的。
Is there anything you've heard about Obama, any sort of rumor that you don't believe, you feel like, ah, that's not true?
有没有你听过的关于奥巴马的传言，你觉得那是不真实的？
I didn't want to believe that. I really didn't. I didn't want to believe that. And, like I said, to this day, I still don't know if I do or I don't, but it makes you stop and wonder.
我不想相信那个。我真的不想。我不想相信那个。而且，像我说的那样，直到今天，我仍然不知道我是否相信它，但这让你停下来思考。
The thing all these Obama stories made me stop and think was, this reminds me of how people used to talk about the Clintons. Thieves, murderers. Hillary Clinton a lesbian, a radical, her college thesis on Saul Alinsky, her health care plan a socialist takeover. It was as though disagreeing on policy was simply not enough for some people to express just how alien the Clintons seemed.
所有这些奥巴马的故事让我停下来想的是，这让我想起人们过去怎么谈论克林顿夫妇。小偷，凶手。希拉里·克林顿是同性恋，激进分子，她的大学论文是关于索尔·阿林斯基的，她的医改计划是一场社会主义接管。就好像在政策上不同意见对某些人来说不足以表达克林顿夫妇看起来是多么异类。
So if winning over Democrats is key to McCain winning Pennsylvania, how can we estimate the number of Democrats who are in fact turning to McCain? Until the election, all we've got to go on is, insert gagging sound here, polls. A Pew Research poll last month said only 12% of Hillary Clinton supporters nationwide said they'd vote for McCain. And a more recent Pew survey said only 4% of Democrats support McCain. Polls, of course, are frequently, and sometimes wildly wrong.
所以，如果赢得民主党人是麦凯恩赢得宾夕法尼亚州的关键，我们该如何估计实际上转向麦凯恩的民主党人的数量呢？直到选举前，我们要依赖的全部就是，此处插入呕吐声，民调。上个月的一项皮尤研究民调称，全国仅有12%的希拉里·克林顿支持者说他们会投票给麦凯恩。最近的一项皮尤调查称，仅有4%的民主党人支持麦凯恩。当然，民调经常，有时极其错误。
Nancy Updike.
南希·厄普代克。
Some people didn't see the sunshine the day after the Weather Underground attacked America. I'm Corbett. I had a caller yesterday who--
有些人在地下气象组织袭击美国后的第二天没看到阳光。我是科贝特。昨天我有一个打电话的人——
While spending weeks in Pennsylvania, we listened to talk radio around the state, and we close our program today with this air check from WILK-FM, 1300 AM, in Scranton/Wilkes-Barre/Hazleton. On October 8, their local drive time host Steve Corbett spent his whole air shift talking about Bill Ayers and Bill Ayers' association with Barack Obama.
在宾夕法尼亚州花了几周时间时，我们在全州收听了脱口秀广播，今天我们以来自斯克兰顿/威尔克斯-巴里/哈兹尔顿的WILK-FM, 1300 AM的空气检查结束我们的节目。10月8日，他们当地的驾驶时间主持人史蒂夫·科贝特花了整个广播时间谈论比尔·艾尔斯和比尔·艾尔斯与巴拉克·奥巴马的关系。
My dad was a cop. I said it before and I'll say it again. And there are other cops, who, because of the Weather Underground, founded by Bill Ayers, Barack Obama's buddy, did not see the sunshine. It's relevant. And I welcome Barack Obama supporters to call us today and defend Bill Ayers and Bernadine Dohrn. I beg them. Call me and defend, on behalf of your candidate--
我爸爸是警察。我以前说过，我还要再说一遍。还有其他警察，因为地下气象组织，由比尔·艾尔斯创立，巴拉克·奥巴马的好朋友，没看到阳光。这很有意义。我欢迎巴拉克·奥巴马的支持者今天打电话给我们，为比尔·艾尔斯和伯纳丁·多恩辩护。我求你们。给我打电话，代表你的候选人辩护——
Then, for the next four hours, from 3:00 in the afternoon to 7:00, he got this huge range of callers taking every position on this. One woman worried that Obama would make Bill Ayers secretary of education. A man accused Corbett of finding fault with Obama only because he, Corbett, had wanted a woman president, that is, Hillary. There was a long conversation with a guy who once lived in a house that the Weather Underground bombed. And then, towards the end of all this, there was this call.
然后，接下来的四个小时，从下午3点到7点，他得到了大量对此持各种立场的听众。一个妇女担心奥巴马会任命比尔·艾尔斯为教育部长。一个男人指责科贝特只因为他，科贝特，想要一位女总统，也就是希拉里，才在奥巴马身上找茬。有一个人和一个曾经住在地下气象组织炸毁的房子里的人进行了长时间的谈话。然后，在这这一切接近尾声时，有了这个电话。
The free for all continues. Dave, caller from Wilkes-Barre, you're in the free for all. Welcome, you're on the air.
无所不谈继续。戴夫，来自威尔克斯-巴里的来电者，你在“无所不谈”里。欢迎，你正在广播中。
How are you doing, Steve?
史蒂夫，你好吗？
Good.
好。
I heard earlier we are talking about Bill Ayers and Barack Obama. I mean, they talk about Bill Ayers being connected to Obama, and you would assume that it would gain a lot of traction in the media and with voters, but it just doesn't seem to be having the kind of impact that you would assume it would have.
我刚才听到我们在谈论比尔·艾尔斯和巴拉克·奥巴马。我的意思是，他们谈论比尔·艾尔斯与奥巴马的联系，你会以为它会在媒体和选民中获得很多推动力，但它似乎并没有产生你以为它会产生的那种影响。
And I think it's because people look at Barack Obama, and I'm one of those people, and we say, the Barack Obama that I see isn't the Barack Obama that would be associated with these people. And I think to myself, what's the implication? Like, all along he thinks that it's OK that Bill Ayers was a bomber, and that somehow in the back of his mind he thinks that this is acceptable behavior. Because I just don't see that.
我认为这是因为人们看着巴拉克·奥巴马，我就是那些人之一，我们说，我看到的巴拉克·奥巴马不是会和这些人有联系的巴拉克·奥巴马。我对自己想，隐含意义是什么？就像，他一直觉得比尔·艾尔斯是个炸弹客没关系，而在他脑后他觉得这是可接受的行为。因为我就是没看到那个。
I see him as an American story that is just amazing. Like, I think that he's lived a middle-class life and he's worked hard and he's raising his family. And he is a man, I think, of extraordinary moral character. And people say, well, the facts say otherwise. But a lot of times, for example, Sarah Palin, she said she's a maverick, where, in some cases, the facts are otherwise.
我把他看作一个神奇的美国故事。就像，我认为他过着中产阶级生活，努力工作，抚养家庭。我认为他是一个拥有非凡道德品质的人。人们说，嗯，事实并非如此。但很多时候，例如，萨拉·佩林，她说她是特立独行的人，但在某些情况下，事实并非如此。
But people, in their heart of hearts, believe that she's really a maverick. So I think so much of this stuff comes down to the impression that these guys make, because we don't really know what's in their hearts and their minds.
但人们，在他们的内心深处，相信她真的是特立独行的。所以我认为这些东西中很多归结为这些人留下的印象，因为我们并不知道他们的心和思想里真正有什么。
You're absolutely right. You're doing exactly what you're supposed to be doing, Dave. You're doing a lot of thinking. People will see what they want to see. And very often, we see the very same set of circumstances in very different ways. But you're doing exactly what you should do. I just wish more people would follow your example.
你绝对正确。你正在做你应该做的事情，戴夫。你做了很多思考。人们会看到他们想看到的东西。而且通常，我们在非常不同的方式下看到同样的情况。但你正在做你应该做的事情。我只是希望更多人能跟随你的榜样。
Thanks.
谢谢。
Thank you. And that's exactly right. He's trying to figure it out. And he knows, as we all know, if we think it through, it's risky. It's risky to go into that voting booth and believe in somebody. I got Ray. No, I got Les in Scranton. How are you doing, Les?
谢谢。这完全正确。他正试图弄清楚它。他知道，我们都知道，如果我们深入思考，这是有风险的。走进那个投票箱并相信某人是有风险的。我有雷。不，我有斯克兰顿的莱斯。莱斯，你好吗？
Hey, Steve. How are you doing?
嘿，史蒂夫。你怎么样？
Good.
好。
[INAUDIBLE PHRASE].
[听不清的短语]。
(HOST) IRA GLASS: Thanks to Steve Corbett and the folks at WILK.
（主持人）艾拉·格拉斯：感谢史蒂夫·科贝特和WILK的工作人员。
Well, our program was produced today by our senior producer Julie Snyder, with Alex Blumberg, Jane Feltes, Sarah Koenig, Lisa Pollak, Robyn Semien, Alissa Shipp, and Nancy Updike. Adrianne Mathiowetz runs our website. Production help from Seth Lind and P.J. Vogt. Music help from Jessica Hopper.
好吧，我们的节目今天由我们的高级制片人朱莉·斯奈德制作，亚历克斯·布卢姆伯格、简·费尔特斯、萨拉·科尼格、丽莎·波拉克、罗宾·塞米恩、阿丽莎·希普和南希·厄普代克参与。阿德里安娜·马西奥韦茨运作我们的网站。来自赛斯·林德和P.J.沃格特的制作帮助。来自杰西卡·霍珀的音乐帮助。
[ACKNOWLEDGEMENTS]
[鸣谢]
Our website, www.thisamericanlife.org. This American Life is distributed by Public Radio International.
我们的网站，www.thisamericanlife.org。《This American Life》由国际公共广播电台发行。
[FUNDING CREDITS]
[资金信用]
WBEZ management oversight for our program by our boss, Mr. Torey Malatia. During this pledge drive that's going on right now, a woman actually tried to get him to pledge. And he said:
WBEZ管理层对我们节目的监督是由我们的老板，托里·马拉蒂亚先生。在现在正在进行的这次认捐活动期间，一个女人实际上试图让他认捐。他说：
Are you out of your ever-lovin' mind, lady?
女士，你是不是疯了？
I'm Ira Glass, back next week with more stories of This American Life.
我是艾拉·格拉斯，下周带着更多《This American Life》的故事回来。
PRI, Public Radio International.
PRI，国际公共广播电台。